fitation de la commission
d'enquête mes chers collègues on
poursuit donc les les travaux de de
notre commission avec l'audition de
Monsieur Dominique buau délégué général
du Conseil économique pour le
développement
durable bonjour monsieur Monsieur
Dominique Jam directeur général de la
Commission de régulation de de
l'énergie Monsieur Philippe vasilopoulos
directeur de développement de de
produits d'pex spot c'est le marché ça
hein c'est bien ça vous vous expliquerez
euh je me dois de vous faire prêter
serement euh en vertu des règles qui
régissent le fonctionnement des
commissions d'enquête parlementair donc
avant de de vous donner la parole je
vous rappelle qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête est
pass possible des peines prévu aux
articles
434- 13-1- 15 du code pénal et je vous
invite à prêter serement de dire toute
la vérité rien que la vérité en levant
la main droite et en disant je le jure
on va commencer par Monsieur
vassilopoulos Merci monsieur monsieur
bureau Monsieur J merci euh et je vous
remercie par ailleurs de nous faire part
le cas échéant de vos éventuels liens
d'intérêt donc le Sénat a constitué le
18 janvier dernier une commission
d'enquête sur la production la
consommation et et le prix de
l'électricité aux horizons 2035 et
2050 nous centrons nos travaux sur le
présent et l'avenir du système
électrique est-il en capacité de faire
face à la demande d'offrir au
particulier et à nos entreprises une
économie à un prix raisonnable quelles
sont ses perspectives de développement
donc l'objet de la de la Table Ronde
d'aujourd'hui est de mieux comprendre
les spécificités des marchés de
l'électricité nous avons commencé à y
travailler lors d'une première audition
le 31 janvier dernier et et nous voulons
approfondir ce cet aspect du de la
question quel est l'utilité réelle de ce
marché qui semble avoir du mal notamment
à délivrer les bons signaux en terme
d'invest tissement de long terme
s'agit-il d'ailleurs d'un vrai marché ou
d'un marché artificiel créé par les
pouvoirs publics nous posons la question
nous vous la posons pourquoi rester sur
le principe du coût marginal alors que
chacun s'aperçoit que cela ne correspond
pas au vrai coût de l'énergie électrique
produite en France et que cela expose
particulier entreprise à des accouts de
prix très préjudiciables on l'a vu
récemment pourquoi conserver une
régulation arè ou postarè alors même
qu'elle bénéficie à des des traders qui
n'ont pas fait l'objet l'effort de se
doter de capacités de production
électrique voilà quelques thèmes sur
lesquels notre rapporteur va va vous
interroger nos et et nos collègues nous
vous proposons de dérouler cette
audition en quatre temps on va vous
laisser 10 minutes pour un un propos la
présentation d'un d'un propos liminaire
euh nous passerons ensuite un temps de
questions réponses en particulier avec
notre rapporteur puis par les autres
membres de la commission collègues ici
présents vous pourrez éventuellement
revenir sur les propos des uns et des
autres évidemment et on terminera par
une dernière batterie de de questions
réponsse je laisse la la parole à
Monsieur le Rapporteur avant de vous la
distribuer merci monsieur le Président
merci messieur d'être d'être là euh
effectivement je moi j'insiste bien sur
les les 10 minutes aussi parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a on a intéress que le
l'audition qui est sous forme de table
ronde qui est pas toujours évidente soit
la la plus nerveuse possible avec le
plus de de questions réponses euh donc
si vous pouvez vraiment vous en tenir à
10 minutes donc parfois c'est un petit
peu contraignant mais euh je dirais
qu'en 10 minutes on arrive quand même à
bien développer son son propos
euh par rapport je je partage les
questionnements du du président là dont
il vous a fait part coup marginal
euh pas mal de choses l'intérêt du
marché
je je demanderaiis moi forcément si euh
il y a eu des évaluations euh de cette
création de marché euh euh évaluation
bien sûr vis pour le consommateur
qu'est-ce que ça a donné
euh est-ce que c'est bien adapté est-ce
qu'effectivement c'est pas un peu
artificiel
euh est-ce que euh voilà on on peut se
poser les questions est-ce que la reine
doit être maintenu ça doit se terminer
en fin 2025 mais finalement qu'est-ce
qu'on fait d'ici là est-ce que est-ce
que c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
maintenir absolument et puis euh moi
j'avais le sentiment que le marché au
départ quoi la la volonté de créer un
marché d'électricité c'était
un petit peu plus pour mettre en
concurrence les producteurs
d'électricité que les les distributeurs
et on a l'impression aujourd'hui qu' y a
des distributeurs qui sont mis en
concurrence mais pas beaucoup les les
les producteurs donc c'est voilà c'est
c'est des des questions dans vos
intervention mais après on y reviendra
peut-être si vous avez pas prévu
forcément les aborder dans votre dans
vos interventions liminires mais bon je
vous laisse tout de suite le la parole
en tout cas je la laisse au
président merci monsieur le rapporteur
je donne la parole à Monsieur Jam pour
commencer allez-y
Monsieur Merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le
rapporteur je vous remercie d'abord pour
l'invitation et pour cette audition en
tant qu'autorité administrative
indépendante la Commission de régulation
de l'énergie est est toujours à la
disposition bien sûr de la
représentation nationale pour éclairer
ses travaux donc on est ravi d'être là
donc quelques mots peut-être et je je
m'entiendrai au 10 minutes je je vous
rassure donc pour euh euh rappeler euh
l'émission de la creux donc la creux a
été créée en 2000
essentiellement par des transpositions
de directives européennes c'estàd que
chaque pays européen comprend une
institution une autorité indépendant de
régulation nous disposons de 160
collaborateurs et nous avons trois
grandes missions d'une part s'assurer du
bon fonctionnement des marchés de
l'électricité et du gaz là où s'exerce
la concurrence donc le marché de détail
l'aval entre le fournisseur ou les
fournisseurs et les consommateurs et le
marché de gros l'amont où s'achète se
vend les volumes d'énergie notamment
entre les producteurs et les
fournisseurs ou les gros consommateurs
industriels qui vont directement sur ce
marché donc l'ament le marché de gros la
va le marché de détail deuxème mission
de la creux nous régulons les réseaux
c'est qu'au milieu de tout ça il y a des
réseaux qui sont des monopoles naturels
réseau de transport d'électricité c'est
RTE réseau de distribution d'électricité
c'est inedis le plus gros distributeurs
et il y a des entreprises qu'on appelle
entreprise local de distribution qui
possèdent des réseaux de distribution
d'électricité locaux donc régul réseaux
ça veut dire s'assurer de leur qualité
de service fixer le tarif d'utilisation
des réseaux l'accès non discriminatoire
et et donc en fixant les tarif
évidemment la maîtrise des
dépenses puisque ces dépenses se
retrouvent ensuite dans la facture des
consommateurs et 3è mission dans le
cadre de la politique énergétique
nationale la creux accompagne la
transition énergétique notamment dans le
développement des renouvelables énergie
renouvelaable qu'elle soit d' électrique
ou gazière avec le biométhane en donnant
des avis sur les textes de soutien
public aux énergies renouvelables et en
instruisant les appels d'offre pour les
plus grosses installations notamment
pour le solaire l'éolien en mer l'éolien
terrestre alors vous avez souhaité
auditionner la Creuse sur le thème de la
fixation des sur le thème des prix de
l'électricité de manière générale et du
fonctionnement du marché donc vous avez
je crois une prochaine table ronde la
semaine prochaine sur les réseaux où
nous serons aussi représentés donc on va
vraiment se concentrer sur la question
des des marchés et je voudrais commencer
par le marché de
gros avec le première notion c'est que
le marché de gros est un marché intégré
européen et qui a notamment un
sous-jacent physique qui est le fait que
l'ensemble de l'Europe est très
interconnecté par des réseaux de
transport d'électricité très
maillé et et c'est ça qui la réalité
c'est c'est pas une création à partir de
rien c'est c'est bien il y a une réalité
physique et le marché intégré et c'est
important permet mais l'optimisation
donc à l'échelle européenne de tous les
moyens de production et de consommation
je rentrai pas dans les détail parce que
l'intervention Despec spot vous vous
rentrera un peu plus dans la dans le
fonctionnement de tout ça et et ses
avantages mais c'est c'est c'est un
point important là encore on pourra
aussi rentrer en le détail mais sur sur
le coout marginal je pense que c'est
c'est important aussi d'avoir en tête
que c'est une un fonctionnement
classique sur le marché de ce qu'on
appelle des commodités commodité c'est
quel quel chose qui a la même valeur si
vous avez une molécule de gaz euh d'où
qu'ell viennent c'est la même molécule
de gaz si vous avez et la différence est
là c'est que à un moment donné un kilwh
d'électricité pour arriver à remplir la
la demande de ce moment-là c'est tous
les kilowurs sont interchangeables qui
sont fait avec du nucléaire ils sont
ensuite dans le même réseau du nucléaire
du renouvelable du gaz du charbon de
l'hydraulique et cetera et et et donc
euh l'idée c'est que c'est d'empiler
jusqu'à arriver au moment
où on remplit la demande il faut bien et
donc il faut bien payer le le le le
dernier et c'est ça la logique du cooup
marginal et c'est un principe en fait
d'économie qui s'applique normalement à
l'économie des
commodités donc c'est pas une invention
quelque part de teocrate à Bruxelles ou
je sais pas où après c'est pas pour dire
que c'est parfait d'électricité excuse
excusez-moi sauf que sauf qu'on a
l'impression que le coout marginal il
s'applique à tout le monde c'estd que je
sais bien que c'est c'est le surplu sur
sur le haut de la pile mais on a que du
coup il sétend à tout le reste qu' soit
prise en compte qu'il soit pris en
compte on peut le comprendre mais c'est
c'est ça qu'on a du mal à comprendrevec
non mais le principe prix marginal c'est
que c'est que ce ce ce fonctionnement
d'empilement à la fin tout le monde
bénéficie du prix marginal et vous avez
sur le prix du pétrole on sait bien que
certains champs en Arabie Saoudite
coûteent peut-être 10 dollars pour la
production mais si le pétrole vaut 80 au
marché mondial c'est 80 donc c'est quand
même c'est quand même un principe contre
lequel il est difficile d'aller et là je
laisserai au moinsexpot qui est qui a la
pratique de tout ça fonctionner alors
ensuite je je va pas rentrer en détail
on reviendra mais
donc ce qui est ce qui est important
c'est que ce système-là il a des défauts
et cetera mais il répond quand même à
des principes d'économie et ensuite et
aussi et surtout il permet de donc
d'optimiser l'ensemble de ses besoins
donc vous vous avez notamment un
couplage entre les interconnexion entre
les pays et les moyens disponibles de
production et les moyens disponibles par
d'effacement de la consommation donc
l'ensemble de tout ça est optimisé en
temps réel ça notre analyse euh
et le point délicat c'est que moi j'ai
pas vu d'analyse globale pour dire que
ce serait-il passé si depuis 20 ans on
était resté dans du monopole parce que
c'est très difficile à faire de récréer
l'histoire de 20 ans de 20 ans donc j'ai
pas d'Al global pour dire euh c'est
fantastique et cetera mais globalement
notre sentiment est que ça fonctionne de
façon très efficace et que notamment ça
a rendu des services importants y
compris pendant la crise pendant la
crise notamment en France on a manqué
d'électricité il a été très important de
de pouvoir notamment mobiliser très
fortement les interconnexions les
importations en 2022 je mais ça existait
avant ça monsieurant avant avant le
marché il y avait des interconnexions et
dans la même situation on aurait pu
importer pour faire face à nos
difficultés absolument je vous avvez
vous av entièement raison la question
est aurait-on pu importer de façon aussi
efficace là la réponse est non très
clairement c'estàd c'est que
l'optimisation de l'ensemble à l'échelle
apporte vraiment une valeur qui se
chiffre à l'échelle européenne en
milliard d'euros par an alors peut-être
aussi avoir en tête que donc la France
dans ce système est en règle générale
exportatrice d'ailleurs nous sommes
revenus redevenus exportateur à hauteur
de 50 TWh en 2023 donc 2022 a été une
année la première année depuis longtemps
où la France a été importatrice puisquon
avait une on avait une difficulté mais
même une année exportatrice en fait la
France va exporter la majeure partie
c'est du temps mais va être
importatrice ce qui n'empêche pas de
dire que ça fonctionnerait aussi ça le
marché ce n'est pas ce que je dis mais
la France va être importatrice
euh à la pointe de froid
euh tous les hivers parce que nous avons
finalement en France peu d'installations
de pointe qui sont les installations au
gaz au file précédemment au charbon et
on en a très peu et donc à ce moment-là
on importe des autres pays qui a donc
plus que nous et le reste de l'année
lorsque ces centrales ne sont pas
utilisées parce que la consommation est
beaucoup plus basse là c'est au
contraire notre parc nucléaire et nos
renouvelables notre hydro qui nous qui
nous permet d'exporter
largement donc ce système là fonctionne
dans ces grands liges depuis 2000 il
s'est optimisé au fur et à mesure il a
atteint un niveau de sophistication très
important et d'efficacité dans notre
point de vue depuis 2 ans ce système a
vécu une crise absolument exceptionnelle
et je voudrais vraiment faire passer ce
message que la crise est exceptionnelle
on espère bien ne jamais revivre une
crise pareille c'est-à-dire que le
principal fournisseur de gaz européen
qui était disponible depuis des
décennies depuis 50 ans a fait défaut
puisque ces exportations chutter de 80 %
pour toute l'Europe de 100 % pour la
France d'ailleurs il y a plus de gaz il
y a plus de gaz russe et en parallèle on
a une crise nucléaire qui n'était jamais
produite ou alors que la production
c'était déjà un petit peu en baisse he
parce que vieillli mais on est à 360 TW
en 2021 et c'était 280 TW en 2022 une
année vraiment de crise de CR donc les
deux crises simultanées euh ça en fait
presque un événement plus que centaire
enfin millénaire si si chacun
voilà on l'espère bien sûr ça s'est
produit une fois ça peut tout se
reproduire mais il faut vraiment avoir
en tête que que cette crise était
exceptionnelle on se rend compte
aujourd'hui finalement qu'on est quand
même sorti de la crise relativement
rapidement les prix du gaz sont revenu
alors toujours une nouvelle crise sont
revenus à un niveau encore un peu
au-dessus d'avant la crise mais un
niveau qui est tout à fait raisonnable
et qui avait déjà été observé par le
passé et pareil pour les prix de
l'électricité ils sont au niveau
significativement plus élevé que ce je
parle des prix gros hein prix gros du
moment significativement plus élevé mais
à des niveaux qui avaient déjà été
observés par le passé voilà et donc
pendant la crise le marché lui il a fait
ce qu'on lui demandait ceon lui demande
c'est fixer le prix un niveau qui assure
l'équilibre offre demande parce queune
rupture d'approvisionnement en
électricité ça c'est un drame pour une
économie pour l'économie d'un pays donc
les fameuses coupures tournantes dont on
a eu tous très très peur l'hiver 2022 23
c'est une disruption majeure de
l'économie donc pour et dans tous les
pays en France mais dans tous les pays
donc pour ne pas y arriver le prix et
c'est valable pour le gaz aussi a monté
jusqu'au niveau où toutes les sources de
production se mettent à produire y
compris les vieux moyens qui étaient à
l'arrêt et cetera qui ressortent pour
parce que le prix est rentable les
effacements ressortte et inversement
évidemment et là il y a du bon et du
mauvais la consommation diminue la
consommation de gaz par exemple en
Europe la Commission européenne un
règlement a été pris a dit - 15 %
objectif pour tous les pays les
objectifs l'objectif a été atteint
certes il y a eu beaucoup de sobriété
des messages des PIR public il y a aussi
eu le signal prix qui a fait que les
consommateurs ont baissé diminuer tout
n'était pas parfait ce marché de court
terme en tout cas il a fait ce qui était
prévu donc évidemment au prix de flambé
de prix insupportable pour nos sociétés
les entreprises comme les particuliers
d'intervention publiqu extrêmement
coûteuse
pour ramener les prix à des niveaux
acceptables et donc c'est bien pour dire
pour ça que clairement le
marché intérieur n'était pas prêt à une
telle crise comme l'Europe de manière
générale d'ailleurs et donc la sortie ça
a été il faut réformer le marché et donc
on a je reviens pas là-dessus parce que
je vaisre trop long mais donc on arrive
à un accord trouvé qui nous semble
positif qui conserve les fondements
économiques dont je pense nous pensons
qu'ils sont efficaces euh et mais qui
apportent une couche de long terme de
stabilisation des prix pour que même en
cas de crise on espère moins forte qui
reviendrait on ait une meilleure
stabilité des
prix vous faites allusion à à quoi par
rapport justement au aux dispositions
nouvelles qui ont été retenu pour
stabiliser un peu plus les chos à
l'accord européen donc au texte dans
lequel le trilogue européen est est
parvenu à bah un nouveau texte qui va
ensuite décliner hein qui est dans le
processus d'adoption qui prévoit
notamment des dispositifs permettant aux
États-membres d'intervenir pour
favoriser la signature de contrat long
terme et établissement de signaux de
prix de long terme il a différents
dispositifs différents types de formes
de contrat notamment pour la France et
c'est un élément important la
possibilité si les PIR public jugent
nécessairire de signer ce qu'on appelle
un contrat pour différence pour le
renouvelable mais ça existait déjà
quelque part mais c'est c'est c'est
pérénisé mais aussi pour le parc
nucléaire existant voilà donc c'est
c'est ce c'est cette cet accord là de
sortie de la crise finalement qui qui
existe aujourd'hui enfin qui n pas
encore dans les textes mais qui va être
transformé puisquil il y a un accord
politique au niveau européen entre le
Conseil et la Commission et si vous me
permettez une dernière parce que je sens
que je vais atteindre les 10 minutes pas
loin vous me permettez un dernier point
parce que
chom un dernier
point pour quand même évoquer c'est
vraiment très important euh il y a plein
de points que j'ai passé que j'ai pas eu
le temps de d'évoquer la question du
marché de détail hein le marché c'est la
concurrence elle est sur l'amament
est réseau au milieu et il y a l'aval
sur lequel les les fournisseurs les
consommateurs tous les consommateurs ont
le choix de leur fournisseur donc là je
vous juste juste faire une référence au
rapport de la creux publié en novembre
2023 sur le fonctionnement des marché de
détail des années 2022 2020 à 2022 donc
années de crise d'abord la crise covid
et ensuite la crise des prix prix dans
laquelle finalement je vais pasre je
vais pas être long et vous vous
m'interrogerez peut-être plus en détail
le le la synthèse c'est que là aussi le
marché il a fait ce qu'il était prévu de
faire en gros à 95 99 % c'est-à-dire que
les fournisseurs ont joué leur rôle ils
ont transmis la valeur de l'arène à leur
consommateur un immense majorité ils ont
transmis les aides de l'État au
consommateurs et des
boucliers
et trè point un un nombre important de
consommateurs était protégés par des
contrats long terme 2 ans 3 ans a PR fix
la plupart des fournisseurs honoré ces
contrats long terme contrat moyen terme
disons à 2 ans ou 3 ans ce qui fait
qu'en fait les clients concernés n'ont
pas eu à bénéficier du bouclier ce qui
est le fonctionnement normal du marché
voilà ça c'est pour dire le positif à
côté de ça il y a des choses qui n'ont
pas fonctionné et donc la creux a tirer
les leçons en faisant les propositions
au gouvernement notamment pour prendre
des mesures ce qui fonction connait pas
donc d'abord certains fournisseurs
n'étaient pas bien couverts donc avaient
vendu à leurs clients du prix fixe
n'avaient pas acheté un amont et donc
lorsque les prix ont flambé soit on fait
faillite pour certains soit on dit au
clients ben je monte le prix et
malheureusement il y avait des petites
clauses qui leur permettait donc ça
représentait moins de 1 % des des
clients mais néanmoins ça existéit donc
ça c'est intolérable et ça doit
absolument ne plus se
reproduire et puis il y a eu des
difficultés aussi avec l'arine on en a
parlé donc voilà la creux à ouvert des
enquêtes pour les fournisseurs qui
aurent eu des pratiques de notre point
de vue anormal et donc les PV on sont
son son sont terminé et sont devant le
comité de règlement des sanctions de la
creux pour sanctions éventuelles et puis
nous avons fait des propositions pour la
suite voilà je veux pas être plus long
merci merci Monsieur Jamin je donne la
parole à Monsieur bureau monsieur
président allumez le micro on vous
entendra mieux si vous pouvez il y a un
bouton voilà VO excusez-moi euh donc
euh merci beaucoup pour l'invitation je
précise que comme c'est c'est suggéré
sur cette planche c'est en tant que
coédacteur de la note du Conseil
d'analyse économique de mars 2023 sur le
triple défi de la réforme du marché
européen de l'électricité que
j'interviens ici et pas au titre je
dirais du ministère de la transition
écologique et de de la la commission
consultative que que j'y anime bon et je
vous prie d'excuser Jean-Michel glchan
et cathine Schoubert qui malheureusement
sont à l'étranger
actuellement qu-ce qu'il faut faire euh
donc tout d'abord en introduction
rappelez que cette note vous avait été
demandée donc à l'hiver de 2022- 2023 au
moment où la question de la réforme du
marché de l'électricité pointait et
d'essayer de tirer les leçons de de
l'expérience de de 2022 euh ce que nous
on en a tiré c'est c'est essentiellement
deux choses d'une part que la crise
avait avait révélé des frag agilité dans
la construction des marchés de
l'électricité c'est-à-dire que comme on
va y revenir
euh il y a il y a des il y a des
chaînons manquant sur la construction du
marché de l'électricité que la réforme
va va sans doute combler mais clairement
il y avait une incomplétude de du
dispositif régulatoire bon évidemment la
crise avait révélé la la dépendance de
l'Europe aux énergies fossiles la
volatilité des prix de l'électricité qui
en qui en sont très dépendants sur le
marché sur le marché de gros et aussi
des problèmes de diversification
d'approvisionnement et cetera euh je
crois qu'au-delà et ça a été un peu le
cœur de notre
réflexion c'est que la crise a montré
que contrairement à ce que on répétait
depuis des années la conciliation entre
décarbonation sécurité
d'approvisionnement et des prix
abordables était quelque chose que le
trépied ou enfin je sais pas comment on
appelle ça en tous les cas concilier les
trois objectifs est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ce qu'on ce qu'on
imaginait et pourquoi pardon excusez
excusez-moi euh alors le le point de
départ c'est c'est de regarder au fond
donc d'avoir au-delà de la crise une
vision un peu prospective et donc dans
dans les éléments clés de la vision
prospective il y a que pour décarboner
l'économie souvent il faut électrifier
ce qui fait que par exemple dans les
scénarios de
RTE on diminue de 35 % ou 40 % l'énergie
consommée mais on augmente de 35 % ou 40
% l'électricité produite parce que parce
que il faut décarboner pour décarbonés
que ce soit le la mobilité par le
véhicule électrique mais aussi le le
chauffage par les pompes à chaleur et
cetera tout ça ça se fait avec de
l'électricité et si on se place au
niveau européen mais le marché européen
j'y reviendrai peut-être plus tard
là-dessus on constate que le marché
européen il est très très loin d'être
décarboné c'est c'est le le graphique en
bas c'est-à-dire que ce que vous devez
avoir en en gris c'est la part des
fossiles on a encore 40 % de de fossiles
dans dans l'équilibre dans le bilan
énerg européen et se passer de la
production élerique non au niveau du
bilan énergétique pardon c'estàdire que
ce que ce que ce que je dis c'est qu'il
faut électrifier pardon c'est dans le
bilan oui c'est dans le bilan production
électrique c'est dans le bilan
électrique on a encore 40 % de fossile
pardon excusem donc donc donc si on veut
décarboner le secteur si on veut
décarboner l'économie il faut avoir
l'électricité voilà on a besoin
d'électricité et d'électricit décarboné
or pour l'instant on est loin d'avoir
d'électricité décarbonée au niveau
européen la deuxième chose c'est que
l'électricité elle est essentiellement
décarbonée par des des sources
intermittentes et et on a besoin aussi
de sources garanties et de de garantie
de production ce qui fait que le le
premier constat c'était que sortir des
énergies fossiles va réclamer des
investissements considérables et bien
bien au-delà des efforts qui sont en
fait
engagé aujourd'hui et et notamment par
ailleurs si on veut assurer la sécurit
d'approvisionnement et donc à cet égard
juste un commentaire ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
totalement différente de celle qui
prévalait en 2000 quand s'est faite la
libéralisation du marché de
l'électricité où on était
fondamentalement en surcapacité et donc
dans ce contexte là le marché de gros
suffisait puisque il y avait pas de
problème d'orienter l'investissement et
de financer l'investissement les le
marché de gros à court terme suffisait
aujourd'hui on est dans un monde
complètement différent où on a besoin de
nouveaux investissements de changer la
structure de notre parc de de fin ça
c'est les c'est l'étude RTE c'est c'est
bah l'étude RTE et la traduction de de
ceci au niveau français mais c'est
absolument structurant pour sur
l'appréciation sur comment faire
fonctionner le marché de l'électricité
dans dans ce contexte je dirais
peut-être mais c'est je pas le mieux
placé c'est peut-être pire même enfin
c'est pire encore quand on regarde au
niveau européen et quand on regarde
aujourd'hui que ce qu'il y avait dans
l'étude RTE des des scénarios mais le
diagnostic qualitatif est bien celui des
scénarios RTE euh et puis alors l'autre
chose l'autre chose mais qui qui est
qu'on devrait savoir parce que c'est
c'est la base de l'économie de
l'électricité on est sur de l'économie
de de
commodité il se trouve qu'à court terme
pour à un instant donné on va devoir
choisir entre des moyens de production
très très hétérogènes pour produire à un
instant donné et puis si on regarde à
différents instants l'électricité elle
est rare ou elle est pas du tout rare
donc on a une situation comme elle est
pas stockable c'est on peut pas
transférer on n'est pas sur un marché
donc le le coût moyen de l'électricité
souvent ça peut pas dire grand chose
parce que on compare un prix à un
instant donné où à la limite les les
éoliennes fournissent à plein et cetera
et on en a presque trop et des
situations euh où on a l'électricité est
devenu un bien très rare et donc faire
la la somme enfin c'est un peu faire la
somme de prix de de de chou enfin de de
navet et de tomate pour trouver un coup
moyen mais donc sur les commodités le
fait que l'énergie est pas avec une
conséquence forte c'est que le prix de
l'électricité sur les marchés de gros il
va être très volatile et ce c'est ce à
quoi on a été confronté avec la crise et
donc la nécessité de traiter cette
volatilité des prix parce que cette
volatilité elle est doublement néfaste
elle est néfaste pour le pour
l'investissement pour la réalisation de
l'investissement je vais je vais y
revenir elle est aussi néfaste parce
qu'on peut pas laisser les consommateurs
exposer à la volatilité des prix de
gros pardon excusez-moi j'ai vraiment
problème euh donc je viens tout de suite
sur l'investissement à cet égard le le
problème de de l'investissement c'est
qu'on veut faire l'investissement
décarboné ça c'est au fond le problème
de l'investissement vert en général et
spontanément l'investissement vert il se
fait pas l'investissement pour
décarbonés il se fait pas pour deux
raisons parce que il est pas très il est
pas rentable parce que économiser du
carbone c'est pas payé ou c'est pas
assez payé donc le problème qu'on a si
on veut faire des investissement vert il
faut que décarbonés soi rémunéré d'une
manière ou d'une autre alors alors ça
j'y reviendrai en partie parce que le
secteur électrique fait partie du marché
européen de l's et donc le secteur
électrique quand il ém du CO2 il doit
disposer de de quota carbone qu'il
achète mettons à 100 € aujourd'hui donc
il paye bien un prix de 100 € la tonnees
de carbone ce qui veut dire que s'il
économise c'est une tonne de carbone bah
il économise aussi 100 € donc il y a un
intérêt pour lui mais qui le prix enfin
le prix du carbone je reviendrai a
longtemps été très FA il est même si on
a l'idée que l'élément stratégique de la
décarbonation de
l'électricité de de l'économie c'est
d'avoir de l'électricité décarboné il
est sans doute trop faible pour inciter
suffisamment les gens à s'engager dans
la sortie des fossiles et ce qui
explique que rétrospectivement B
l'économie européenne
l'électricité européenne est resté
dépendante des fossiles en dépit des
subventions sur les les renouveles
l'autre chose c'est que ces
investissements ils sont risqués ils
sont risqué sur des pour des raisons
technologiques ils sont risqués aussi
parce que au fond ce qui rémunère le
fait de décarboner ça va être le prix du
carbone sur le marché ets celui-ci il
est volatile et donc évidemment un
investisseur qui va investir sur pour
décarboner l'économie pour faire un pour
faire des pour financer un opérateur
électrique qui va se lancer dans dans
dans dans les différentes technologies
qui permet de faire de l'énergie
décarboné que ce soit prolonger la durée
de vie des centrales que ce soit
décarboné que ce soit
faire les choses avec la biomasse ou je
ne sais quoi c'est toujours extrêmement
risqué ce qui veut dire qu'un
investisseur va mettre des primes de
risque tout à fait élevé pour pour
accepter de mettre de l'argent là-dessus
donc spontanément l'investissement est
fait donc le problème majeur qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est se met dans cette
perspective où on a besoin de de recréer
des surcapacités et des surcapacités
décarboné et des des surcapacités qui
fournissent des garanties
d'approvisionnement dans ce contexte là
le marché de gros il reste rempl çable
il estremplaçable ça vient d'être
expliqué à quoi il sert il sert qu'à
chaque instant on va utiliser on va
appeler les équipements on a des
équipement hétérogène à un instant donné
on a une certaine capacité d'énergie
d'électricité fatale intermittente on a
une certaine capacité de nucléaire
disponible comp tenu de la gestion du
parcè et on a intérêt à les appeler par
ordre de mérite et ça ça change à chaque
instant et donc le marché de gros il
fonctionne comme un mécanisme d'enchère
qui permet d'assurer l'équilibre de
l'offre et de la demande en s'assurant
que l'énergie elle est produite au
moindre coût c'est-à-dire que quand on a
de l'énergie qui vaut rien enfin ou qui
coûte rien à produire bah on utilise ses
moyens de production et on va pas
chercher des choses qui vont être
extrêmement coûteuses on va pas all
piocher dans l'hydraulique dont on aura
absolument besoin si c'est si c'est de
hydraulique non au fil de l'eau et
cetera donc si on veut avoir de
l'électricité pas chè globalement on a
intérêt à minimiser le coût de
production et ça c'est ce que nous
fabrique le marché de gros c'est-à-dire
qu'à chaque instant on va utiliser au
mieux le par qui est disponible par
rapport à la demande qui elle- même est
extrêmement variable en fonction de en
fonction de des nuages et cetera ça ça
bouge en permanence donc ça on en a
besoin ce marché de gros il est quand
même aussi important pour financer
l'investissement parce que pourquoi on
va pourquoi quelqu'un va financer de
l'investissement pour avoir moins de
coût variable bah il faut que ça paye
donc il va dépenser de l'argent pour
avoir l'investissement et il va dépenser
il va accepter de dépenser de l'argent
parce que il y a quelque chose qui va lu
venir du profit bah le profit c'est
qu'il fait des rentes inframar in
c'est-à-dire qu'à un instant donné
l'électricité qui qui vend a une
certaine valeur qui qui est très élevée
et donc éventuellement en ayant un parc
plus plus capitalistique qui va
permettre d'avoir moins de coût variable
mais par contre évidemment la
contrepartie c'est qu'il faut investir
et qu'il faut financer l'investissement
donc de ce point de vue là jusqu'à un
certain point le le marché spot il sert
aussi à financer les
équipements pardon non non
mais excusez-moi par rapport à ça moi
moi c'est surtout vous dites c'est
irremplaçable c'est indispensable pour
des investissements futurs mais les
investissements futurs il faut avoir la
visibilité et en réalité là-dessus on n
pas de
visibilité donc c'est c'est ça qui qui à
mon avis est gênant quand même on vient
au cœur du rapport qui est de constater
que il est nécessaire pour faire
fonctionner on en a besoin pour faire
fonctionner le marché de l'électricité
il concour au financement des
investissements mais il a trois
insuffisances et les insuffisances se
sont rappelées c'est le cœur du rapport
c'est de dire il y en a une insuffisance
qui est connue qui qui est liée à
l'histoire de l'électricité c'est
qu'évidemment euh c'est enfin c'est la
théorie de Marcel Boiteux on devrait
faire payer les pointes bon personne
aucun responsable politique ne
laisserait augmenter les prix de
l'électricité au moment de la super
poointe
hyperpointe au niveau de prix qui serait
nécessaire pour équilibrer l'offre et la
demande et ce d'autant moins que à court
terme la demande les gens ils ont des
possibilités d'effacement mais elles
sont à court terme si les les anticipe
ils en ont d'autant plus mais à très
court terme c'est très inélastique et
donc on aurait des prix donc
historiquement et structurellement sur
le marché de l'électricité on ne peut
pas mettre les prix à la pointe au
niveau qui serait nécessaire pour
pouvoir financer les investissements et
ça c'est c'est c'est inhérant au secteur
électrique c'est-à-dire c'est ce qu'on
ce que les anglosaxons appellent missing
mononey c'est-à-dire que la la
tarification de gros est insuffisant la
tarification idéale que préconisait
Marcel boîux permettrait de financer
l'investissement les tarifications
réelles qu'on est obligé de mettre en
place le marché de gros ne suffit pas
pour financer l'investissement ce qui
nécessite de de combiner avec soit des
des des des des des en des systèmes dans
lequel on paye aussi pour la puissance
des systèmes sur lequels on met des
marchés de capacité et cetera mais on a
besoin d'instruments complémentaires
pour assurer le développement de
l'investissement c'est-à-dire que les
marchés de gros effectivement vous avez
pleinement raison les marchés de gros ne
suffisent pas pour orienter et financer
les investissements qu' qu'on a besoin
de faire ensuite la deuxème raison c'est
la question c'est qu'on fait des
investissement et le le design des
investissements qu'on veut faire on veut
qu'il soit décarboné ça c'est justifié
par les objectifs climatiques mais
clairement il faut que ce soit rémunéré
et le prix du carbone n'est pas
suffisant pour inciter suffisamment les
producteurs à se décarboner au rythme
auquel on le souhaiterait donc là encore
on a un défaut de retour sur
investissement sur les investissements
qu'on voudrait faire pour décarboner
l'économie et puis la troisième chose
c'est ce que j'ai déjà expliqué c'est le
fait qu'on va avoir des prix qui sont
très volatiles que ces investissements
il nécessitent des anticipations sur les
prix du carbone futur et donc que que
des investisseurs privé normalement
constitués ils vont exiger un couple
retour enfin risque retour et cetera qui
fait qu'ils vont mettre des primes de
risque qui sont très importantes et donc
le financement de ces investissements
est difficile l'autre chose comme j'ai
déjà dit cette volatilité elle est aussi
inacceptable pour les
consommateurs
donc le principal élément qui qui est
qui est mis en avant c'est
qu'effectivement il faut de il faut
compléter il s'agit pas de supprimer le
marché de gros mais il faut le compléter
et notamment le compléter par des
instruments notamment qui vont permettre
de financer l'investissement
c'est-à-dire de créer des condition dans
lequel ça redevient rentable d'investir
dans des dans des investissements
décarbonés ou dans des investissements
qui assure la garantie
d'approvisionnement et pour ça bah il
faut dérisquer ou sécuriser hein c'est
ce qu'on fait en politique industrielle
pour la décarbonation de l'industrie où
on fait aussi des des mécanismes on a un
peu le même genre de problème donc on a
besoin de mettre en place des mécanismes
euh bah dans lequel
euh
l'investisseur sera dérisqué du par
rapport à à l'anticipation de volatilité
et ça ça se passe par exemple euh l'idée
c'est d'avoir un mécanisme c'est ceul
mécanisme qu'on a déjà déjà sur sur
certains sur certains appels d'offre
renouvelables o on met un prix
d'exercice quand le prix de quand le
prix de du carbone le prix de référence
est très élevé bah c'est bon là
finalement l'investissement il se
rentabilise lui-même avec des prix
élevés donc il il y a rien à faire par
contre à contrario quand on est dans des
situations où je sais pas parce que la
la demande est faible et à ce moment-là
tous les prix sont déprimés à ce moment
et à ce moment-là l'opérateur
d'électricité anticipe qu'il sera pas
capable de financer ses projets bah dans
ce cas-là il y a un complément il y a un
complément de de revenu pour
assurer un niveau je dirais de
rentabilité minimale de l'opérateur pour
que ces contat pour que ces
investissements à long terme qui sont
des investissements risqué supporte un
risque qui est raisonnable alors soit
c'est l'état soit enfin c'est l'état le
contribuable qui le fait ça et ça fait
partie de la régulation soit ça peut se
faire directement par des arrangements
où il y aurait un industriel qui veut de
je sais pas développer un
électrocatalyseur qui a besoin
d'électricité et cetera pour pour
produire de l'hydrogène et à ce
moment-là on arrive à faire rencontrer
l'offre et de la demande et trouver des
garanties dans dans cet arrangement
simplement ces cas-là sont des cas un
peu particuliers on a besoin plus
génériquement de de donc de ce qu'on
appelle contrat pour différence mais ce
qui a déjà été défini donc ce qu'on ce
qu'on insiste c'est que ces instruments
sont complé ire et qu'il est important
après c'est un peu de la la technique
mais ce que mais c'est c'est le diable
est dans les détails c'est de trouver
des designs de ces instruments qui
soient efficaces c'est-à-dire
que par exemple si on met des contrats
de long terme on veut préserver aussi
l'efficacité du marché de gros donc il
faut trouver des solutions c'est pas
forcément très compliqué et bah il faut
que la garantie elle s'exerce sur un
volume prédéfini de manière à ce que les
gens restent pleinement insérés sur le
marché de gros par exemple enfin bon
donc il y a de même si le le contrat à
long terme il est sur une durée
excessive avec un prix trop favorable il
sera une barrière à l'entrée donc il
faut que le régulateur surveille et
fasse les arbitrages pour que les les
prix à long terme pour que ces contrats
à long terme soit compatible avec la
concurrence soit compatible avec
euh soit compatible avec enfin avec les
incitations à l'efficacité dans
l'utilisation du parc et soit aussi
compatible avec la la concurrence VO je
crois que j'ai terminé c'est bon voilà
j'ai terminé j'ai juste oublié de dire
que de même de même que on peut pas les
laisser les
opérateurs globalement on ne choisit pas
un opérateur ce qu'on veut c'est qu'il y
a des gens des opérateurs qui
investissent et pour qu'on investisse on
a besoin de ces mécanis de même on peut
pas laisser les consommateurs exposés à
une volatilité excessive et il faut
aussi que dans les contrats de détail on
développe des instruments qui permettent
au consommateurs de pas être soumis à
des des problèmes de volatilité excessif
voilà JECI merci merci Monsieur le
bureau Monsieur
vassilopoulos Merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur tout
d'abord merci d'auditionner epexpot
alors epexpot c'est la European power
exchange c'est la bourse de
l'électricité
paneuropéenne on n'est pas négociateur
d'électricité donc on nachète pas on ne
vend pas d'électricité on organise la
confrontation la plus large possible
entre l'offre et la demande donc c'est
ça notre métier au quotidien donc tous
les jours on opère une enchère qu'on
appelle l'enchère deed la veille pour le
lendemain qui permet la confrontation la
plus large entre les acheteurs et les
vendeurs sur un sur une zone de de prix
donné donc en France ou en Allemagne en
Autriche en Suisse et cetera donc dans
pratiquement la quasi totalité des des
marchés européens l'objectif de cette
enchère ou le le gros des volume vont se
vont se retrouver et de bien entendu de
définir un prix et ce prix il est
fondamental parce que c'est ce prix qui
va permettre à des installation à
travers toute l'Europe de démarrer ou de
s'arrêter au bon moment donc ce prix de
l'électricité ce signale prix il va va
permettre à tous les acteurs à tous les
les opérateurs de centrale mais aussi
aux consommateurs de savoir à quel
moment il faut consommer d'électricité à
quel moment il faut en produire avec
leur outil de production ou avec les
unités de consommation donc ce premier
rôle il est important je dirais d'un
point de vue d'un point de vue national
d'opérer cette confrontation la plus
large la plus démocratique possible
entre l'offre et et la demande il y a un
deuxième rôle qui est fondamental qui
est l'optimisation des interconnexions
et qui permet à travers ce qu'on appelle
le le mécan de couplage des marchés
d'utiliser au mieux donc d'optimiser les
capacités d'interconnexion les capacités
transfrontalières entre les différents
pays européens ce qui va être un élément
très important parce que ça permet de
mutualiser les mix et de d'utiliser les
mix de production au mieux à travers les
différents pays européens alors je peux
vous donner quelques quelques exemples
ça permet par exemple en période de très
forte de très forte consommation en
France quand les températures sont très
basses et c'est une des caractéristiques
du système électrique français d'être
très thermos sensible euh de par
l'utilisation du chauffage électrique ça
permet à la France d'importer et de
pratiquement saturer ses interconnexions
à l'import autour de 14 14000 MW en
terme de capacité d'import mais ça
permet aussi à la France d'importer
pendant les périodes de très fortes
production éolienne ou solaire dans les
pays voisins lorsque les prix sont
baches chez les voisins ça permet
d'importer de l'électricité moins
coûteuse à la France ça permet aussi
d'exporter les surplus nucléaires quand
les voisins ont des prix plus élevés par
rapport au au prix français et ce qu'il
est important de de de de mettre en
évidence c'est que ce calcul est un
calcul purement économique c'est-à-dire
que on a une le le le l'objectif de la
Bourse qui va recevoir tous les matins
l'ensemble des carnets d'ordre des
centaines d'acteurs qui opèrent sur le
marché électrique européen donc ces
carnets d'ordes on va les agréger en une
courbe d'offre et une courbe de demande
et c'est l'intersection de cette courbe
d'offre et de cette courbe de demande
qui va permettre de définir le prix
c'est purement mécanique c'est-à-dire
que c'est un calcul de presséence
économique qui qui permet de satisfaire
la demande dans une zone donnée à
moindre coût tout en prenant en compte
les opportunités d'échange aux
frontières donc à travers les
interconnexions et c'est ce double rôle
que va faire la bourse au quotidien
alors depuis le l'arrivée des des
énergies fatales intermittente notamment
l'éolien et le solaire on a un autre
rôle qui est de permettre au système
électrique de s'équilibrer le le plus
finement possible avant le temps réel et
avec l'intermittence c'est un enjeu qui
est considérable parce qu'on peut avoir
des variations de production assez
important tente d'une heure sur l'autre
que ça soit de la production éolienne ou
de la production solaire à la hausse
comme à la baisse qui vont demander aux
acteurs et notamment au aux acteurs qui
ont de la consommation ou de la
production de pouvoir réagir face à un
signal prix pour permettre un
équilibrage du système électrique avant
que le gestionnaire de réseau de
transport prenne la main à travers le
mécanisme d'ajustement pour s'assurer
Infiné qu'en temps réel l'équilibre
offre demande sera sera préservé donc ce
rôle ce rôle de la Bourse il est devenu
de de plus en plus important avec
l'arrivée des des énergies renouvelables
il va le devenir encore plus de par le
contexte actuel le contexte actuel est
le suivant c'est qu'on se prive
aujourd'hui d'une d'une artère qui
permettait de ramener du gaz en Europe
et on devient de plus en plus dépendant
d' LNG qu'on va faire venir de l'autre
bout du monde ce ces apports de LNG
rendent l'Europe plus sensible au
variation météorologique notamment plus
est-ce qu'on va avoir assez de vent sur
une année donnée pour couvrir une par
partie de la demande avec de l'éolien
est-ce qu'on a assez de sooleillement
pour couvrir une partie de la demande
avec du solaire et surtout est-ce qu'on
a assez de gaz s' fait extrêmement froid
en Europe pour satisfaire la demande de
de pointe et donc on a un système qui
depuis la la crise énergétique qui est
encore en
cours d'une certaine manière de par le
le l'impossibilité d'importer du gaz du
gaz rus à travers nthstream cette crée
cette sensibilité du du marché européen
qui demande une réactivité des acteurs
donc la capacité de pouvoir démarrer des
unités ou d'en arrêter en fonction des
besoins du système donc on a des
situations où on risque d'avoir trop de
gaz parce que les cargos LNG sont
bloqués sur les ports dans les ports et
que la consommation finalement ne permet
pas d'évacuer ce gaz ou des situations
où on en aura pas assez parce que par
exemple une une phase hivernale
extrêmement rigoureuse une une période
hivernale extrêmement rigoureuse qui
peut se traduire par une baisse très
forte des stocks de gaz et donc qui va
demander de de de de palier à cette
absence de gaz par soit plus de cargo
LNG qui seront déviés par rapport par
exemple à des cargos qui seraiité parti
en Asie ou d'autres moyens de production
et et cette crise elle a été elle a été
exacerbée en parti par les problèmes sur
le l'outil de production nucléaire
l'année dernière avec les les questions
de corrosion sous contrainte qui ont
fait que cette c'est ce que Dominique
Jam mentionné précédemment on a eu une
sorte de combinaison de trois facteurs
une hydroélectricité un niveau
d'hydroélectricité faible en Europe euh
avec une une situation de sécheresse
assez particulière sur l'année sur
l'année l'année écoulée une une partie
du mix électrique qui était hors d'usage
de par à cause des questions de
corrosion sous contrainte donc en France
avec pratiquement la moitié de la
capacité qui était qui était à l'arrêt
et avec une une situation très très
tendu sur le marché gazier et des prix
extrêmement élevés qui ont mené du coup
à un coût plus élevé pour produire à
partir des centrales au gaz notamment
des cycles combinés et qui ont eu
l'impact qu'on a pu voir sur sur les
marchés de l'électricité ce qu' est très
important donc dans cette phase où
l'Europe va devenir plus sensible aux
variations météorologiques c'est de
pouvoir aussi compter le plus possible
sur les voisins de pouvoir faire jouer
la solidarité européenne et c'est ce
qu'on a vu au au au plus haut de la
crise finalement tous les les pays
européens ont joué le jeu ont maintenu
les exports dans le cas de pays
exportateurs et et et bien entendu ça ça
a permis à la France d'importer et
d'éviter des situations plus difficiles
avec des rationnements ou des des
coupures tournantes aujourd'hui cette
situation évolue dans l'autre sens parce
que finalement avec une disponibilité du
nucléaire qui s'améliore on est la
France est capable d'exporter de
d'augmenter la quantité d'export vers
vers les pays
voisins alors peut-être un un un un
dernier mot pour dire que finalement
dans cette dans C dans cette
logique le rôle des marchés est
fondamental mais pour que le marché
puisse jouer son rôle il faut qu'il soit
liquide et ça c'est la caractéristique
principale du marché de gros plus il est
liquide ça veut dire plus la
participation est large plus les volumes
sont ant plus la fiabilité du prix est
forte est maintenue et on on a une une
certaine confiance qui s'installe donc
liquidité ça veut dire confiance dans
les processus de formation de prix et
c'est aussi ces mécanismes qui
permettent de limiter les les primes de
risque par exemple qu'on a pu voir en
France au plus haut de la de la crise et
donc c'est un élément important si on
veut que demain les marchés jouent leur
rôle à fond il faut leur permettre de se
développer il faut leur permettre d'être
le plus liquide les plus liquide
possible puisque c'est la meilleure
garantie qu'on aura que le prix sera le
sera juste sera établi au bon niveau et
et que la concurrence puisse s'exprimer
à fond donc il est important de prendre
en compte dans les politique publique de
de demain cet élément de manière à
développer les marchés qui vont nous
permettre une résilience et une une
solidarité entre entre les pays
européens et donc qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez et bien par exemple ce que ce
qui se passe actuellement de remplacer
l'arè par un mécanisme autre qui a
plutôt tendance à aller dans le sens
d'une liquidité accrue sur les marchés
va dans le va dans le bon sens ça veut
dire quoi ça concrètement mais
c'est-à-dire que le le mécanisme qui a
été décrit précédemment aussi par
Dominique l'idée de plafonner les prix
pour pour permettre de de protéger le
consommateur c'est une bonne idée mais
il faut que ça se fasse à travers le
marché sur la base de référence de prix
de marché et non pas sur des références
à hoc et dans cette logique on peut en
même temps permettre au marché au marché
français de d'augmenter sa volumétrie
donc sa liquidité de prendre sa place
centrale sur le marché européen et et de
préserver finalement l'intérêt des
prodeurs et des consommateurs on fait
abstraction de de des caractéristiques
par exemple du parc du parc nucléaire
français là pas du tout comends
simplement je comprends pas franchement
là ce que vous dites là et bien on va
utiliser des références de prix de
marché finalement pour pour le marché
c'est le marché après il y a une réalité
industrielle alors les références des
prix à terme par exemple ce qui
permettrait déjà de de développer la
liquidité sur les marchés à terme on
parle souvent de visibilité on va
pouvoir créer de la visibilité à 10 ans
seulement si on arrive à créer de la
visibilité à 3 4 ans donc par exemple en
compensant les écarts par rapport au
prix de marché aujourd'hui on parle d'un
prix de 70 € du mgawh par rapport à quel
prix et par rapport à à quelle
finalement logique quelle réalité sur
les marchés et bien par rapport à la
référence du prix de gros de
l'électricité pas très monsieur le
rapporteur merci merci à vous mais
j'avoue que la dernière intervention me
laisse un peu lupitatif parce que
honnêtement quoi pour moi en tout cas je
comprends rien donc euh je sais pas si
mes collègues si mes collègues
comprennent bien euh vous dites vous
voulez rendre les marchés plus liquides
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
honnêtement alors vous dites il faut
l'élargir le marché on l'élargit à qui à
quoi sur quoi sur quel volume sur je je
je sais pas moi je comprenais que les
marchés servaient effectivement à
échanger des offres et des demandes ça
je comprends parfaitement qui a une
solidarité européenne elle existait
avant il y peut-être pas forcément de
marché et elle est déjà était déjà
présente donc est-ce que d'ailleurs une
de mes questions c'est est-ce qu'il faut
renforcer ces réseaux parce que ça coûte
très très cher quel intérêt quel intérêt
la France a là-dedans parce que moi je
je raisonne jeux je suis européen mais
je risonne déjà français donc je me dis
quel intérêt la France a là-dedans
sachant que nous on est plutôt
structurellement exportateur on l' vu
sauf sauf une année 2022
particulière on espère qu'elle sera
exceptionnelle j'en sais rien si sera
exceptionnel parce que les les la
géopolitique actuelle et il y a pas mal
d'éléments qui font que on peut penser
que il y aura il y aura des éléments
encore de de secous et de variation qui
qui risquent d'arriver donc à un moment
donné si on cherche à servir le
consommateur et la compétitivité de
notre pays il faut qu'on ait le prix le
plus bas bon est-ce que c'est le marché
qui qui détermine le prix le plus bas
j'en sais rien je je sa j'en sais rien
non mais peut-être mais à vous de nous
le démontrer à vous de nous démontrer
l'intérêt de renforcer les réseaux
d'échange parce que aujourd'hui est-ce
que on perd beaucoup d'électricité par
moment qu'on arrive pas à vendre parce
que moi moi c'est ça qui qui m'intéresse
je me dis bah on est structurellement
exportateur mais si à un moment donné on
produit de l'électricité qu'on arrive
pas à vendre ou qu'on
qu' pour laquelle on est obligé de
payeril Y a parfois des prix négatifs on
est obligé de payer pour pour la vendre
moi je trouve ça quand même très
embêtant sachant ça ça nécessite des
investissements colossaux donc euh et
euh au niveau européen quels sont les
pays qui sont structurellement
importateur parce que Sin nous on est
structurellement exportateur il y a des
pays qui sont structurellement
importateurs est-ce qu'ils vont le
rester euh voilà est-ce que vous avez en
connaissant le marché est-ce que vous
avez une vue un peu de tout cela qui
permettent de nous orienter dans les
choix qu'on peut être amené à faire au
niveau français sachant qu'on est là
nous pour euh pour effectivement aider à
la décision sur les décisions à prendre
dans pour les les 10 15 25 années à
venir donc c'est vrai qu'il faut voilà
et et et moi le marché alors j'entendais
monsieur Jam mais il dit ah B oui on a
il y a pas eu d'évaluation mais on peut
penser que c'était utile moi moi je je
veux bien votre point de vue je je je le
respecte mais j'aimerais bien savoir
pourquoi finalement on ne fait pas
d'évaluation pourquoi il y a pas une
étude précise évaluant pour le
consommateur qu'est-ce qu' a apporté le
marché par rapport à la situation
précédente voilà qui à quoi on a échappé
éventuellement qu'est-ce de quoi on a
bénéficié euh moi je trouve ça un petit
peu dommage qu'on est pas on n pas ce
genre d'élément visiblement personne l'a
fait mais bon voilà vous permettez une
une réponse monsieur le Président sur ce
pointl
eu bon vraiment vraiment je pense bien
sûr c'est regrettable qu'on n pas cette
étude de l'ensemble de de bilan
simplement le marché il est ouvert
depuis 2000 et il est ouvert
complètement depuis 2000 7 ça fait 15
ans et et c'est très compliqué vraiment
dans C c'est un problème de d'analyse de
d'imaginer ce qui se serait passé si le
marché nit pas été ouvert c'est
peut-être pour ça que l'étude n'a pas
été faite il faut sans doute qu'on
revienne vers ça nous on a juste une
étude mais qu'on a toujours c est creux
jamais vraiment valorisé parce que
monsieur le président m'a fait la
remarque est parfaitement pertinente qui
dit que par rapport à une situation où
les marché seraiit pas interconnecté
c'est 34 milliards d'euros par an que le
marché européen apporte de création de
valeur
mais vous avez raison il y aurait des
échanges même s'il n'y avait pas un
marché européen intégré donc c'est c'est
pas forcément quelque chose qu'on met
qu'on met en valeur donc là-dessus je je
je prends le point non je voulais vous
juste vous dire quelques quand même des
éléments d'appréciation supplémentaire
peut-être c'est que le marché européen
électricité il est vraiment dans une
dynamique on n'est pas dans une
stabilité on est en train de changer de
monde mais réellement à grande vitesse
et ça c'est ça c'est important parce
qu'on a vécu depuis les années 80 90 y
compris 2000 et même même 2010 avec un
par nucléaire notamment en France solide
installé qui était jeune à l'époque il
faut produiser plus de 400 on est à plus
de 400 TW chaque année cette année on
est mieux mais on est qu'à 320 donc on
va encore remonter les objectifs sont
monté à 350 mais on retrouvera pas les
400 et surtout surtout on avit une
stabilité de la demande depuis
maintenant 10 ou 15 ans
pardon c'est vrai pardonnez-moi
pardonnez-moi ESP espérant qu'on les
retrouve et c'est vrai qu'on va de toute
façon avoir probablement un réacteur
supplémentaire qui va rentrer qui
apportera une dizaine de terw donc
peut-être qu'on les retrouvera mais
enfit c'est
jusqu'à présent on est on est on est on
est encore à 320 sur
2023 on remontera 350 sur 24 et 25 c'est
ce qui est prévu par F lui-même donc
mais ce qui est important limite c'est
là on parle de quelques quelques
dizaines de terraur ce qui important
c'est la dynamique on est dans une
électrification et ça c'est vraiment
important monsie bureau l'a dit j'avais
oublié de le préciser j'avis pas eu le
temps forte dans la perspective de la
décarbonation de notre société donc on
est on a reenclenché une très forte
dynamique d'augmentation de la la
consommation non mais je pense que ça on
peut partager c'est et la consommation
d'énergie au global va diminuer on va
tous faire la sobriété mais
l'électricité va fortement augmenté on
l' pas encore vu mais le marché on l'a
pas vu en 2023 ah non mais alors je me
place à 2035 2050 ah mais absolument ce
qui se dit c'est que jusqu'en 2030 ça va
pas être aussi significatif que cela et
que ensuite ça ça peut décoller plus
fortement vous avez en enfin bon c'est
c'est c'est un peu RTE qui nous dit ça
et on est on a on a effectivement la
crise a a commencé par un énorme effort
de spéalité de sobriété qui fait qu'on
repart en niveau un peu plus bas et
l'incertitude sa quit va repartir mais
la dynamique est là on va on a quand
même et là pour le coup là on le voit je
pense qu' a dû vous le dire il a des
demandes par exemple sur les zones de
décarbonation industrielle incroyable on
les voit parce qu'on voit les
investissements on les voit et donc on
est à quelques enfin plusieurs gigaw de
de choses qui sont en train d'être signé
RTE va lancer les investissements pour
que les industriels qui soient fuses à
dunkererque dans la vallée de de la
chimie à Lyon au Havre il y a il y a
plusieurs autres zones puiss se
décarboner ça c'est enclenché ça mettra
quelques années ça sera 28 29 30 mais là
la là le demande va être là la mobilité
électrique elle va aussi être là euh les
les pompes à chaleur vont vont vont se
développer en quoi le marché dont on
vient de parler qui nous a été présenté
dont vous
parlez facilite ça alors c'est c'est
c'est c'est quel est la valeur ajoutée
non non du point de vue de l'intérêt
général national en l'occurrence est en
France
du marché par rapport euh à ce cadre de
transition écologique qui appelle
l'électrification des usages la
décarbonation et cetera c'est c'est
c'est-à-dire que euh le le le le parc
nucléaire va représenter au fil du temps
une proportion moindre quand même qu'on
le veuille ou non de la production
nationale et et donc et ça va être
remplacé par quoi pas par du pilotable
comme on avait auparavant du charbon ou
du gaz par du renouvelable et le
renouvelable il est il est par
construction il produit en masse sur
l'année il produit mais il va produire
énormément à certaines heures de l'année
trop on aura même d'électricité parfois
qui en aura trop on saura pas on saura
pas quoi en faire et donc il faudra bien
l'exporter ou le stocker ou la stocker
voilà c'est l'électricité fatale que ce
soit l'éolien ou le photovoltaïque c'est
ça à d'autre moment il improduira très
peu donc les signaux de prix et la
meilleure façon de gérer ça c'est encore
d'avoir un signal de prix et d'avoir
qu'à certaines heures ça vaut 200 € à
d'autres ça vaut 0 ou 10 €. et que donc
les gens qui vont devoir développer des
batteries de l'hydrogène pour pouvoir
des électrolyseurs pour pouvoir stocker
l'électricité sur d'hydrogène et ensuite
la réutiliser et cetera et cetera et ces
signaux de prix donc c'est c'est c'est
pas pour dire que c'est la la panassée
mais vu les enjeux économiques qui sont
à l'ch européenne en centaines de
milliards d'euros même pour notre pays
je j'ai pas donner des chiffres exact le
fait de baser ça sur des signaux
économique transparent clair qui
représente la vraie valeur ça ça a
vraiment une valeur pour l'économie je
pense que c'est effectivement présenter
comme ça c'est un acte de foi mais mais
la l'idée c'était on n'est pas dans une
stabilité par rapport au monde
d'électrique d'avant ça c'est ça c'est
important et et donc les solutions
d'avant sont ne peuvent pas être
simplement dupliqué en se disant ce qui
marchait dans années 90 2000 pourrait
fonctionner dans les années 2020 2030
c'est une question qu'on se pose je je
comprends je comprends très bien qu'elle
soit posé absolument est tout à fait
légitime merci je je je je passe la la
parole à mes collègues qui souit vous
poser des questions victorien Lurel et
Daniel oui merci monsieur le Président
euh à votre avis donc le marché est
efficace et donc il faut vous dites la
meilleure manière c'est d'avoir des
signaux et le meilleur signal c'est le
prix donc un
marché efficace
efficient il y a combien d'opérateurs
sur ce marché
epex vous avez combien d'opérateurs
combien d'acteurs
parce que dans la théorie parce que je
finis dans la théorie un marché efficace
un marché atomistique c'est comme ça
qu'on dit la tomicité il y a beaucoup
d'intervenants là j'imagine qu'il y a
quelques acteurs importants et d'autres
qui ne sont pas couvert et il y a des
garants dernier ressort sur l'efficacité
donc du marché moi j'ai bien M pression
avant c'est ce que disait le Président
il un moment ça marchait quand même
c'est boiteux et c'était des grands
messieurs
m Louis Armand ceux ont mis au point
c'est vrai ce qui existe en théorie
économique et d'ailleurs il y a même des
théoriciens écrivent sur la société du
coup marginal zéro c'est les entreprises
de réseau et ce sont les monopoles
naturels ce qu'est par
exemplef on a imposé donc au nom d'une
théorie parce que la France a voulu à
une certaine époque garder les tarifs
réglementés de vente l'EUR refusé ça
donc on a nos méchants sorts deux fois
qui dit et bien on va vendre 25 % de la
production électrique de de DF et donc
on va créer un marché artificiel
messieurs moi je pense ça c'est lel qui
parle que ce marché n'existe pas le
marché de l'électricité tel qu'il est
évoqué là tel qu'il est écrit dans les
bouquins marchait avant ensuite
l'interconnexion bien sûr qu'il existe
mais ça représente à peine 10 % des
échangers et des flux euh ça c'est
toujours fait avant aujourd'hui on me
parle de marché européen la France est
connectée avec l'Allemagne béneluxe
Italie Espagne ok mais quand on cherche
le prix tel qu'il est formé c'est
quelques acteurs qui décide que le prix
de reviens qui a entre 40 et 70 € et
bien est vendu au consommateur final
entre 200 280 300 parfois même 400 on a
on a vu ça et pour vous c'est efficace
ça veut dire on a a pris je dirais les
choses clairement moi les dividendes de
DF qu'on a privatisé et on a créé des
rentes de situation pour quelques
opérateurs et qui d'ailleurs se sont
ravisés lorsque le prix du marché était
inférieur à au prix de la reine je
m'interroge donc sur l'effectivité de
marché efficace et et et le ce qui
explosé la part personne ne pose la
question je vous la pose y a-t-il un
système alternatif y y a-t-il une
révolution systémique à faire avec les
lois qui ont été prise la loi qu'on va
nous soumettre là qui est déjà en avant
projet est-ce que on repense le système
et on repense le marché tel qu'il
fonctionne aujourd'hui et qui est
prétendu être efficace moi j'en doute
très sincèrement et si on va plus loin
et je m'arrête là je suis déjà TR
président euh il me semble que on
cherche un équilibre re 70 % c'est ça de
nucléaire et le reste en autre énergie
euh
notamment
intermittente quelle est l'efficacité à
long terme de l'injection de d'énergie
interminante non stockable et à tout
moment surtout lorsqu'il y a des pointes
quel est l'intérêt du pays France sur
cette orientation
stratégique je voilà je suis déjà trop
long il a autant de commentair question
je passer la la parole à à Daniel salmon
juste une une petite question euh par
rapport à ce que vient de dire victorien
Lurel est-ce que
Monsieur
vassilopoulos excusez-moi euh la
suppression vous appelez vous souhaitez
la suppression des tarifs réglementés de
l'électricité pour justement
mieux liquidifier je sais pas comment on
dit les les les marchés puisque voilà
vous avez dit voilà vous répondrez à la
question je tout à l'heure Daniel salmon
oui merci
c'est vrai que ce marché pendant
quelques temps on s'en est pas
franchement inquiété c'estàd jusqu'à ce
qu'il y ait cette crise
ukrainienne bon il y avait des
fluctuations mais on nétait pas arrivé à
ces à ces coûts complètement faramineux
donc on a vu ce qui se passait en cas de
crise et il faut toujours envisager les
crises effectivement elle a été sévère
mais vous dites que on a fait on a
apporté quelques réformes à avec les
contrats par pour différence les les
BPA alors comme j'ai du mal à à
raisonner en en macro prenons des si
vous pouvez nous donner des cas
particuliers une entreprise aujourd'hui
ou un ou un particulier
d'ailleurs dans une situation de crise
comme on a conduit en
2022 quelle va être sa situation
grâce au contrat for difference et puis
au PPA qu'est-ce que ça va lui apporter
vraiment voilà c'est et puis sinon euh
les questions de de mon collègue Lurel
étaient très très très très
intéressantes j'ai entendu aussi une
tendance peut-être à raisonner euh
franco-français est-ce que
euh qu'est-ce que la France a gagné
qu'est-ce qu'elle a à perdre c'est
vraiment ça aussi parce que on entend ça
assez souvent creusons un peu
l'affaire vous vous avez la parole qui
qui veut commencer monsieur bureau
peut-être ess en étant
synthétique pour tout le monde pas
de tout d'abord peut-être sur sur le je
pense le changement d'état d'esprit par
rapport à ce qui était fait
effectivement on n pas rencontré de
crise on a essayé à la marge du du
marché de gros qui avait été mis en
place de résoudre un certain nombre de
problèmes qui
euh qui qui au fond interagissait pas
forcément bien enfin qui qui réglait pas
à la base le le le problème qu'on va
qu'on qu'on voulait traiter je vais
revenir sur les problèmes de de
sécurisation et de risque c'est-à-dire
qu'on a inventé effectivement un
dispositif d'arine mais qui ressemblait
à une assurance sauf que les gens payent
pas de prime d'assurance quoi et donc
quand quand quand ça va bien quand ça va
bien ils disent qu'ils ont pas besoin
enfin ils ont pas besoin et puis quand
tout d'un coup quand ça va mal alors là
ils se précipitent et cetera bon et un
mécanisme d'assurance qui fonctionne il
faut que les gens ici il y a un
transfert de ris transfert de risque à
quelqu'un qui va le supporter et et donc
on peut pas avoir des des dispositifs
dans lequel pile je gagne fasse tu Perre
quoi bon et donc or c'est un peu ce
genre de choses qu' on été mis en place
et dont il y avait besoin de sortir et
pour nous la conviction c'est que la
bonne manière de s'en sortir euh c'est
non pas en demandant en ayant une
discussion je dirais un peu qui qui a
pas de solution si je dis au niveau
académique aujourd'hui que vous alliez
au MIT vous vous allez en France tout le
monde dit marché hybride parce que
personne n'a la vraie bonne solution
c'est-à-dire que les problèmes qu'on a à
résoudre sur le marché électrique du
futur ils sont tellement gros que celui
que n'importe quelle personne qui vous
dit moi j'ai la bonne solution je sais
comment faire le de marché il suffit de
revenir à ce qui existait dans le passé
et cetera c'est pas les mêmes
technologie il y avait quand même des
lacunes sur l'orientation de la demande
les effacements et cetera aujourd'hui on
est confronté avec des des sujets qui
sont tous beaucoup plus aigus et donc
bien présompteux celui qui dit moi j'ai
la solution parfaite il suffit de de
revenir euh problè
problèm non mais attendez moi je suis
j'ai été rapporteur de Marcel Boiteux
pour un certain nombre de rapports je
suis j'ai pas encore remis de son décès
et mais je pense que le les les
problèmes qu'on a à résoudre et les ce
qu'on est sûr c'est que pour faire
fonctionner le marché de l'électricité
il fallait reconstituer ce qui se
faisait à l'intérieur de DF non pas le
dispatching mais justement sur
réellement la répartition et l'appel par
ordre de mérite et de fait ça ça a été
fait non mais justement ce que ce que je
dis c'est que ce
qu'on pardon voilà par contre si vous
vous placez de manière donc le marché il
il refait on peut discuter à l'infini
s'il le fait mieux plutôt un peu mieux
plutôt un peu moins bien mais
effectivement il refait l'appel par
offre de mérite et il le fait en
utilisant des mécanisme d'enchère qui
qui on mérite d'être compatible avec la
concurrence et éventuellement d'avoir
des entrants et d'avoir
d'avoir des des gens en plus et
peut-être que là il y a des bénéfices
mais on peut discuter à l'infini est-ce
que les bénéfices de d'avoir plus de
concurrence compense enfin que sur
componense des inconvénients de
simplicité et cetera ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'on est dans un monde qui va
être beaucoup plus
volatile pourquoi qu'est-ce qu' va y
avoir aujourd'hui ou dans le passé on
s'en sortait la consommation était
volatile parce que les les gens et enfin
cont tenu du chauffage et cetera donc il
y avait une volatilité côté du côté de
la demande mettons avec la météo
aujourd'hui on a la volatilité des deux
côtés du côté de la météo et du côté de
l'offre et qui vont et les aléas se
cumule c'est-à-dire qu'on est dans une
situation où les marchés appelonsles les
marchés quel que soit leur mode de
régulation d'organisation vont être
confrontés à un monde où à chaque enfin
la
volatilité ce qui fait que la question
est-ce qu'on est unimportateur net
exportateur net c'était quelque chose
qui faisait vraiment sens euh je dirais
dans jusqu'à au début des années 2000 où
là effectivement on était toujours
exportateur net et les les flux
d'importation et
d'exportation il y avait un sens majeur
aujourd'hui on est avec des des systèmes
électriques nationaux qui sont tous
soumis à des allées considérabl et qui
ont tous besoin les uns des autres et la
question c'est que comment faire que
chacun compte pas sur les autres euh
pour pour être le garant en dernier
ressort mais donc on est dans des
systèmes qui sont beaucoup plus exposés
et de ce point de vue-là la crise a
montré que le système interconnecté a
permis de fonctionner et c'est pas sûr
que ça aurait si bien fonctionné que ça
si la France avait été seule pendant
l'année 2022
avec la situation de son parc
électronucléaire et cetera c'est pas sûr
que ça aurait marché donc là vous avez
sur 2022 si si on fait l'évaluation
rétrospective 2022 ça aurait pu mal se
passer sans les interconnexions donc je
pense qu' il faut le compter j'en viens
peut-être plus concrètement à vos deux
questions comment ça marche concrètement
les CFD les CFD généraux contre pour
différence c'est intégré au marché de
gros c'est-à-dire que le producteur
d'électricité il vend sur le marché de
gros donc il reste intégré sur le marché
de gros par contre lui il a besoin
d'être dérisqué et donc il y a quelqu'un
qui lui donne soit soit il lui donne des
des compensations supplémentaires quand
le prix du marché gros est trop bas soit
euh soit euh soit lui il paye
éventuellement si le marché est trop
élevé bah il en restitue une certaine
partie à la la puissance publique comme
on l'a eu pendant la crise de de 2020 22
sur les les certains contrats
renouvelables donc euh simplement ça ça
se passe entre l'État et l'opérateur qui
a signé un contrat de long terme le
marché de gros il fonctionne il continue
à fonctionner les gens sont bien sur le
fonctionnement comme je l'ai dit il faut
avoir un design qui ne pervertisse pas
le comportement du producteur en
question sur le marché de gros mais
fondamentalement on est compatible avec
le marché de gros et donc on ce qu'on a
fait c'est qu'on a conservé les marchés
de l'électricité et on a rajouté en plus
des marchés qui sont des sortes de
marchés d' assurance qui font bah que
selon l'état de la nature les gens vont
vont avoir un transfert dans un sens ou
un transfert dans un dans un autre si
vous mettez sur du côté du consommateur
c'est le genre de mécanisme qu' qu'on
doit imaginer c'est un peu similaire si
vous êtes vous très exposés parce que
vous avez un chauffage et cetera vous
avez besoin d'être exposé contre une
explosion de de prix de l'électricité
bah il faudrait que vous puissiez passer
un contrat pour une quantité garantie
qui vous dise que bah si jamais le prix
sur le marché de gros dépasse telle
valeur vous aurez une compensation à un
certain niveau sur là encore sur un
niveau forfatisé pour que vous ayez pas
intéressé intérêt à tricher et cetera
mais donc ça va être fondamentalement de
mettre que les consommateurs puissent
faut pas qu'ils soi exposé directement à
la volatilité du marché de gros par
contre c'est il faut qu' qu'il qu'ils ai
accès à des contrats qui au fond combine
à la fois le prix de l'électricité dans
sa réalité physique telle qui ressort
des marchés et d'autre part des
mécanismes d'assurance qui font que il
soit protégé contre la volatilité du
prix et donc ce qu'il faut fabriquer
c'est la combinaison de ces deux de ces
deux outils en le faisant proprement
c'est-à-dire reconnaître qu'on a besoin
de marché de gros pour orienter les
choix de production et cetera qu'on a
besoin de marché d'assurance pour se
protéger contre la volatilité et que si
on essaie de tout faire avec un seul
instrument alors que on a des problèmes
de volatilité d'assurance qui sont
beaucoup plus compliqués donc c'est pas
un triturant en bridant en essayant de
faire des choses sur le marché gros on
va tout faire mal c'est-à-dire qu'on va
être on va vouloir faire avec un seul
instrument euh résoudre de problèmes he
d'efficacité d'allocation parre de
mérite de l'autre de protéger les
différents acteurs exposés au risqu et
tous les acteurs sur le marché de
l'électricité sont exposés à des risques
considérables le moyen de ça c'est
d'avoir des des des outils qui euh bah
qui qui rendent compatible et qui
réduisent leur expositions au risque
quand ils en ont vraiment besoin en
contrepartie du fait qu'ils vont payer
l'équivalent de prime c'est-à-dire que
s'ils ont un prix de référence qui qui
est fixé dans le cadre du CFD il y a des
fois c'est eux qui vont rendre de
l'argent à l'état voilà donc il y a pas
un mécanisme dans lequel on gagne à tous
les coupsaccord donc tout pour le marché
monsieur vassilopoulos s'il vous plaît
alors ça va absolument dans le sens de
de ce que j'allais dire aussi c'est il
faut un marché qui soit liquide par
liquidité je vais essayer d'être un
petit peu plus plus clair que que
précédemment par liquidité on entend la
quantité d'acteurs qui vont s'échanger
de la de l'électricité donc qui vont
acheter et vendre c'est c'est ce qui
fait la qualité d'un marché finalement
c'est ce qui fait sa compétitivité aussi
et et c'est là où finalement la reine
n'est pas un mécanisme de marché bien au
contraire l'arine est un mécanisme
complètement hors marché c'est pour ça
que enlever écoutez nous nous ce qui
nous intéresse à la commission d'enquête
c'est ce que paye le consommateur quel
qu'il soit c'est ça le le le sujet donc
marcher plus ou moins de marcher plus ou
moins de prise en compte de la réalité
industrielle du par de production en
terme de coût euh voilà c'est ça qui
doit concourir à la formation du prix et
à ce que paye le le le consommateur
final voilà dans une optique
euh notamment de de compétitivité pour
l'économie française utilisatrice de
d'efficacité environnementale et et et
de et et d'économie aussi euh pour pour
le le consommateur le consommateur de
base c'est c'est c'est ça le c'est ça la
question de fond absolument mais
monsieur le Président ce qui ce qui fait
le le le prix final du consommateur
c'est l'empilement de certaines
composantes donc la partie
approvisionnement énergétique la partie
réseau et la partie taxe c'est ça les
trois composantes principales là je
parle exclusivement de la partie
approvisionnement énergétique plus le
marché de gros nous le sentiment c'est
que le on on aimpression que le marché
est
déconnecté de de de cette réalité
d'empilement composantes euh que que
vous évoquez voilà c'est c'est c'est ça
c'est ça enfin je parle pour moi hein je
sais pas si c'est partagé mais mais mais
mais c'est ça pour nous pour nous la
question et et s'il vous plaît je je
voudrais que vous répondiez à la
question que je vous ai posée euh vous
vous appelez à plus de liquidité au
niveau du marché comme certainement y il
y en a pas selon vous suffisamment la
donc vous vous appelez aussi à la
suppression totale de de tous les les
les les processus de régulation de
protection ti peu tu arrivrive
réglementer c'est ça pas exactement déjà
peut-être pour avoir les choses des
ordres de grandeur en terme de liquidité
pour une consommation électrique
équivalente la France a une liquidité
sur ses marchés de gros à peu près 6 à 7
fois moindre que celle de l'Allemagne
donc on a un marché beaucoup moins
liquide pour une consommation à peu près
équivalente maintenant pourquoi parce
que on a mis en place à travers les deux
dernières décennies depuis l'ouverture à
la libéralisation des mécanisme dont
laaren en fait partie dont le tartame
avant laaren qui était le le
prédécesseur de laarine qui ne
permettent pas à la liquidité du marché
de se développer qui qui qui verticalise
d'une certaine marché d'une certaine
manière les volumes entre le
consommateur et et un producteur et ces
mécanismesl ne sont pas de nature à
aller apporter de la liquidité et à
créer un prix de référence qui soit le
plus robuste le plus fiable possible et
l'affaiblissement de DF à
l'occasion de la mise en place et du
fonctionnement de la reine ça ça ça en
fait sûrement partie c'est pour ça que
c'est un mécanisme qu'on a que depuis
son premier jour on demande à ce qu'il
ne soit pas implémenté du C au moins du
du côté d'accord é contémes Ty DEP
maintenant plus donc les tarifs
réglementés j'y reviens qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait alors les tarifs réglementés la
question est pas tellement de la la
question du tarif réglementé c'est son
niveau c'est sa sa mise à jour
aujourd'hui les tarifs réglementés ont
un gros désavantage c'est qu'ils ne
permettent pas au clients final de
répondre de réagir à un signal tarifaire
aujourd'hui donc dans pour une certaine
partie des des consommateur c'est un un
un frein finalement à leur réactivité
face à des événements par exemple
certains leur permettent au consommateur
de s'adapter euh à la période au moment
et cetera euh voilà c'est pas c'est pas
si simple que ça quand même et et c'est
pour ça que c'est pas aussi simple il
faut maintenir des tarifs de pour par
exemple les consommateurs en précarité
énergétique on doit maintenir des tarifs
réglementés pour les protéger est-ce que
ça veut dire qu'il faut que tous les
consommateurs résidentiels et puissent
bénéficier de tarifs réglementés en tous
les cas c'est une exception
française monsieur Jam alors euh
quelques quelques petits mots c'est
c'est très compliqué parce que le sujet
est vraiment complexe et j'en suis
vraiment
désolé peut-être un premier point sur
pour revenir à ce que vous disiez sur
l'important c'est ce que P les
consommateurs on partage évidemment la
mission de la creux s'exerce au bénéfice
des consommateurs toutes les mission
d'AC s'exerc au bénéfice des
consommateurs c'est vrai qu'il y a un
premier point sous-jacent qui est déjà
que à l'échelle de la société le
fonctionnement du parc électrique et du
système électrique soit optimisé c'est
tout bête mais mais c'est déjà un point
important et ça même si j'ai pas une
preuve mathématique de ça on a tous les
éléments n permettent de penser je pense
qu'ici on est tous d'accord que le
fonctionnement à court terme du marché
intérieur européen permet ça permet à
tout moment que c'est le ça coûte le
moins cher possible et d'ailleurs ça les
moins possible de CO2 de faire
fonctionner le système ça ve qui ne veut
pas dire que l'argent dégagé va au
consommateur oui
mais la command des différents moyen de
production je vous vous vous avez raison
mais mais c'est là que la notion de
dynamique est vraiment important et que
le système électrique d'aujourd'hui déjà
et de demain ne ressemble vraiment plus
pas du tout à celui à celui d'hier et je
voudrais juste illustrer encore ce
point-là par un autre point c'est de
l'illustration sur la diversité
d'acteurs que le marché en fait
peut-être qu'il a été créé par une
décision
collective de Bruxelles en 1996 une
première directive mais aujourd'hui il
existe et la diversité d'acteurs même en
France et si on va à l'Europe c'est
encore encore encore diversifié vous
avez bien sûr les producteurs mais les
producteurs vous avez EDF vous avez les
producteurs central gaz c'est c'est déjà
EDF total ngj vous avez des producteurs
de renouvelabl des dizaines et des
centaines on gère les appels d'offres
renouvelabl pour vous assurer que c'est
un marché complètement concurrentiel EDF
existe là-dedans comme Total comme NG
mais il y a une multitude d'opérateurs
hein et là il y a vraiment aucune
domination que dans l'igopole à 3 comme
on peut le voir mais vous avez au-delà
vous avez d'autres choses vous avez des
gros consommateurs industriel qui vont
eux même sur les marchés pour essayer
d'optimiser leur facture vous avez des
opérateurs d'effacement qui viennent
soit chez un industriel chix soit chez
des particuliers installer des boîtiers
pour s'effacer aux heur de pointe créer
de la valeur participée vous avez des
gens qui gèent des stockages qui posent
des batteries ça va arriver de plus en
plus pas encore en France très peu mais
ailleurs ça existe déjà y compris chez
les particuliers en autoconsommation o
qui pose des batteries pour arbitrer
répondre au système vous avez des
autoconsommateurs individuels collectif
donc voilà vous avez les fournisseurs
les grands les petits les fournisseurs
de gaz les fournisseurs renouvelables
les fournisseurs et cetera bon donc
cette diversité là elle existe et c'est
c'est aussi en ça que le monde
d'aujourd'hui déjà et de demain c'est
pas le même quand même que celui des
années avant l'ouverture ou tout début
de l'ouverture du marché voilà juste un
mot je suis désolé je je je vais faire
des peut-être des choses mais il faut
quand même dire un mot de
l'arine vu du régulateurs de l'énergie
que nous sommes la Run est un dispositif
qui a rempli sa mission 95 99 % qui est
de faire passer au consommateurs ce
qu'on appelle la rente nucléaire
c'est-à-dire le fait que le parc
nucléaire est capable de produire
existant produire à un coût raisonnable
assez stable dans la durée donc il était
valable pour 15 ans entre 2011 2026 il a
fait ça pendant des années sans que ça
sache trop parce que quand le marché
vaut 50 55 42 ou même quelque fois 35 et
que l'arène est à 42 ça fait un petit
cadeau enfin un petit bénéfice pour les
consommateurs mais pas beaucoup pendant
la crise que lorsque les prix de gros
ont flambé il a joué un rôle énorme
c'est grâce à la reinene notamment que
les consommateurs français ont été mieux
protégés qui soit entreprise ou
particulier que qu'ailleurs dans le
reste de l'Europe il faut le dire après
il avait des tas de défauts de défauts
majeurs le 42 € n'a jamais évolué 42 €
en 2012 42 € en 2024 on comprend bien
qu'il y a un problème effectivement
d'affaiblissement de DF c'est son bon
terme monsieur le Président il y a un
problème au il y a un problème
clairement de de calage et puis il y
avait des difficultés qui ont toujours
qui étaient toujours passé sous le radar
parce queit pas assez de valeur mais
pendant la crise il y avait tout un tas
de possibilités d'arbitrage dans les
règles qui avaient là aussi pas été
anticipé pour pour des prix qui
montaient à 100 200 500 € plus de 1000 €
en hiver euh alors que la reine est à 42
et donc il y a eu des cas où que nous
considérons comme abus d'arine donc on a
ouvert les enquêtes qui vont bien elles
sont aujourd'hui devant notre organ de
sanction qui est qui constit de deux
magistrats de la Cour de cassation et du
Conseil d'État qui est en train de
regarder ça voilà c'est resté je ve le
dire ici c'est resté marginal en volume
ça a existé donc voilà donc c'est mais
mais au global laarenne a quand même
réellement permis de servir à la facture
des consommateurs
voilà les bénéficiaires de laarine
étaient censé produire aussi oui alors
ça s'inscrire dans dispositif de
production oui ça pas été fait alors les
bénéficiaires de la reine les
intermédiaires qui qui avaient de la
reine dans leur portefeuille pour
ensuite voilà alors le problème est que
est que dans la mesure où cela était
possible on peut considérer que ça a été
fait c'était possible sur les centrales
au gaz les centrales au gaz entre 2009
100 et aujourd'hui on a quand même 13
stations représentant 6 Gow qui nous
sont bien utiles pour passer la pointe
et puis pour gérer un hiver qui ont été
construit donc c'est en gros aujourd'hui
il y a des rachats donc c'est un/ers
total un/ers NJ un/ers DF mais celà a
été construite sans un centime de de
soutien public et puis vous avez
toujours renouvelable alors là il y a du
soutien public parce que ce sont des
appels d'offre publi mais qui sont qui
est concurrentiel et dans lesquels
beaucoup de fournisseurs pas tous bah se
participe aux appels d'offre c'est
concurrentiels ils gagnent il gagnent
pas et donc petit à petit ils
construisent une partie de leur
portefeuille d'approvisionnement
là-dessus mais pour le reste le parc
nucléaire est-ce qu'il est l'hydro à la
situation Industri qui est la sienne et
n'ont pas été ouvert et et donc on peut
pas faire un procès je crois au au aux
concurrents d'EDF sur le marché aval de
de de ne pas avoir développé qu qu éta
quelles étaient les technologies qui éta
qui étaient
disponibles alors donc ça c'est je
voulais faire sur laarine et puis je
voulais ver avant faire peut-être pardon
oui excusez-moi mais moi j'ai encore des
questions à poser donc je vourais pas
que le temps passe trop vite et que j'ai
pas pu poser mes
questions donc sur le fonctionnement du
marché bon je vous défendez plutôt le
marché même si il est pas très liquide
voilà bon j'ai bien entendu le
gouvernement en septembre et octobre
2022 à l'époque c'était Bruno Leem puis
ellisabeth borne ont annoncé que ils
avaient le souhait de
déconnectter l'évolution du prix de
l'électricité de du prix du gaz
euh ils ont dit qu'ils allaient agir en
la matière est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est réalisable ou pas ou est-ce que
c'est un vux pieux parce que j'ai
entendu dire que effectivement par
rapport au marché ce qui est pas
illogique qu'on utilise le coût marginal
parce que effectivement sinon personne
n'investit dans le coûp marginal si à un
moment donné il doit il doit fournir
alors que il est pas rémunéré quoi donc
personne ne le
fera ça je je peux parfaitement
comprendre mais est-ce que ce qui a été
annoncé et ce qui nous paraîtrait plutôt
souhaitable parce que effectivement le
le gaz étant très volatile c'est quand
même embêtant de de lier à travers le
marché le prix de l'électricité à ce ce
prix du gaz moi je je trouve ça je
trouve ça quand même embêtant donc
est-ce que d'abord vous pensez que c'est
c'est jouable ou pas du tout depuis
depuis septembre 2022 voilà il s'est
passé il s'est passé quandême plus d'un
an on l'a pas senti bon deuxième chose
par rapport à la liquidité du marché
vous dites il faut marché de plus en
plus liquide donc ça veut dire que vous
voulez pas des PPA parce que les PPA ils
ont plutôt tendance à réduire la
liquidité du marché si je comprends bien
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est des
accords que que l'on passe des gens qui
investissent dans des dans des
infrastructures et que donc il passent
pas par le marché hein ils ont un prix
d'électricité qui leur est garanti un
volume et un prix et donc ça c'est pas
dans le marché donc c'est ça rend ça va
pas dans le sens de la liquidité que que
vous défendez
donc je sais pas d'ailleurs comment
l'augmenter cette liquidité parce que
vous dites ça serait souhaitable j'ai
300 300 acteurs actuellement sur le
marché il y en a sans doute
effectivement quelques dizaines qui sont
des très important et d'autres qui sont
quand même assez assez
marginaux voilà je vois pas très bien et
puis ma troisème question c'est la
question que j'ai posé au départ mais
sur laquelle vous nai pas du tout
répondu c'est l'intérêt de renforcer les
les interconnexions moi je vois
l'intérêt des interconnexions jeis
l'intérêt des interconnexions mais si on
a des interconnexions une solidarité
européenne qui se fait alors que nos
politiques sont très différentes parce
qu'on a des politiques de production
énergétique qui sont quand même assez
assez à
l'opposé finalement est-ce que on va pas
se retrouver devant un système qui
finalement les pointes sont les mêmes
chez tout le monde donc quand quand les
énergies renouvelables vont produire
elles vont produire un peu partout parce
que quand il y a du vent à un endroit il
y en a souvent ailleurs quoi c'est c'est
pas toujours le cas c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est pas toujours toujours le cas
mais enfin en tout cas on peut se poser
les questions est-ce que est-ce qu'il y
a des études qui ont été faites
là-dessus est-ce qu'on y voit clair euh
moi je demandais euh lors d'une
précédente audition que l'on puisse
avoir un état des prévisions de
consommation et des prévisions de
production ça sur le plan annuel mais
après à l'intérieur des des années sur
le plan saisonnier aussi qu'on se dit
tiens comment on passe l'hiver comment
on passe les pointes comment on fait ça
moi je je pense au caractère incitatif
quand même du tarif euh en fonction des
heures je pense que les contrats les
contrats différenciés heur plein heure
creuse et autre je pense que c'est une
bonne chose après tarif réglementé faut
voir comment il est calculé comment il
est appliqué j'en sais rien laarine ça a
sans doute une
utilité est-ce qu'il faut continuer dans
ce sens-là est-ce que l'accord va
remplacer bon tout ça pour moi c'est pas
encore très clair mais c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué hein le sujet de
l'électricité est pas simple c'est pour
ça qu'on s'y attaque et qu'on essaie de
clarifier les enjeux aussi pour nos
compatriotes pour voir l'intérêt de la
France essayer de donner des des des él
de de d'aide à la décision et de de
choix et puis ensuite aider aussi nos
compatriotes et puis les entreprises
aussi du pays à être plus compétitive
voilà donc trois questions le le
couplage avec le gaz est-ce que c'est un
moment donné on peut on peut penser que
ça on puisse s'en sortir est-ce que les
PPA ça réduit pas la liquidité du marché
du coup est-ce qu'il faut et et les
réseaux européens avec la solidarité
européenne
et je sais pas qui veut répondre
peut-êre essayer de répondre à la
première question
euh déconnecter le prix de gros
l'électricité de celui du gaz je pense
que c'est pas possible et c'est pas
souhaitable c'est-à-dire que quand on
est à un moment oou de fait ce qu'on va
acheter c'est à la marge c'est de
l'électricité GNL ou de
l'électricité russe ou je ne sais où et
cetera
euh ce le prix qui émerge sur le marché
il reflète bien que s'il y a un
consommateur qui demande un kil ur de
plus bah pour la collectivité ça coûtera
le fait de payer euh le les importations
de gaz au prix qui sont donc déconn
supprimer déconnecter le prix de
l'électricité le prix du gaz faut savoir
de quoi on parle si on parle du prix de
gros je pense que c'est pas possible par
contre si on parle de
déconnecter la facture que per des
ménages de la volatilité des prix de
gros qui résultentment des prix du gaz
là il y a beaucoup de choses à faire et
euh typiquement c'est généralisé ce
qu'on a fait pendant la crise pendant la
crise on est parti sur le bouclier
tarifaire le gros inconvénient du Pr du
bouclier tarifaire c'est que finalement
bah les gens éétaient pas incités à à
réduire leur consommation
progressivement on est passé sur des
dispositifs dans lequel on expose les
gens au prix marginal du du gaz donc
pour une fraction de leur consommation
il conservent bien inérêt à essayer de
se de de faire des de s'effacer d' d'en
faire le moins possible mais par contre
ils reçoivent une prise
pas par le chèque énergie et cetera qui
est différencié selon leur situation ce
qui fait que sils sont S sont les
ménages qui vont bénéficier le plus de
la prime la partie sur la
fraction de l'électricité qui consomme ù
s'applique le prix le prix du gaz pour
faire vite
devient très limité sachant que sur
toute leur premier kilwh consommé on a
admis que cela ils étaient
incompressibles et donc en fait là il
les payent au prix du gaz moins le moins
le le chèque énergie qui leura été versé
donc ce dispositif qui a été inventé
dans l'urgence pour déconnecter la
facture du prix du gaz on n'a pas réussi
et progressivement il y a eu pas mal de
débat dans notre groupe beaucoup de
discussions clairement les les pays qui
ont essayé de de enfin qui ont
complètement mis des boucliers
tarifaires sont pas forcément ceux qui
ont le mieux réagi dans dans la crise
même s'ils ont appris et qu'ils ont
corrigé relativement vite ce qui est le
cas de la France mais donc je crois que
vre idée c'est qu'il faut oublier cette
idée qu'on va
déconnecter le prix gros de
l'électricité en commençant par celui-là
par contre on a besoin d'instrument pour
déconnecter la facture que payent les
gens quand les prix du gaz sont sont
élevés mais qui doivent être conçus
plutôt comme des dispositifs d'assurance
en conservant un prix marginal qui reste
plus lié au prix de gros parce que c'est
celui-là qui compte pour la collectivité
les gens qui consomment parce que parce
qu'on leur donné le bouclier tarifaire
et qu'on qu'on importait du gaz bah ça
ça s'est retrouver dans la balance
commerciale du pays enfin bon donc c'est
c'est ça qu'on qu'on veut éviter j'en
profite peut-être pour répondre à la
question sur le prix final nous aussi on
est obsédé sur avoir qu'au bout du bout
le prix de l'électricité il soit le plus
bas possible pour pour les pour pour
pour le consommateur final entreprise ou
ménage si on regarde de très loin le
fonctionnement l'électricité qu'est-ce
qu'il faut pour ça il faut que le parc
soit bien dimensionné parce que au fond
si vous avez sous-investi vous allez
avoir des rentes bon et puis si vous
avez surinvesti il va falloir payer les
surinvestissements donc la question clé
c'est comment qu'est-ce qu'on met dans
le dispositif actuel pour faire qu'on va
avoir le parc dont on a besoin à
l'horizon 2040 2050 et et cette question
là elle est pas tellement sur le marché
de gros elle est vraiment sur la
question comment on incite à à faire les
bons choix d'investissement et au bon
niveau par les opérateurs qui pourrait
le faire voilà un tout petit mot et
cette question est rendue beaucoup plus
complexe par le fait que tout ça est
très dynamique et que on sait que la
demande va croître en 2050 sera très
importante mais la dynamique est pas
évidente donc si on va trop vite qu'on
fait trop de renouvelable tout de suite
par exemple que la demande est pas là on
va peut-être avoir des prix qui vont
très bas mais qui vont mettre en
difficulté les producteurs si on est
trop l au contraire les prix vont monter
donc c'est ce que je disais sur la
dynamique du système qui est vraiment
pas la même et qui fait que l'exercice
est compliqué Monsieur Je je pose la
question en souriant un peu c'est la
raison pour laquelle la PPE tarde à à
nous être mis au débat ou proposer ou ou
parce que c'est ça c'est ça finalement
le c'est la PPE c'est c'est la question
de la de la PPE que que que que vous que
vous POS par nom de la commission je
parle même que c'est la PPI pardon c'est
la programmation pluriannuelle des
investissements dont on a besoin
effectivement on a besoin de
dispositifou dans lequel on s'assure
est-ce que les investissements qui sont
programmés à 5 ans à 10 ans à 15 ans en
fonction et cetera est-ce que au fond il
correspondent à ce dont on a besoin et
comment on fait si on pense qu'il y a un
écart comment on fait pour le combler en
anticipant alors c'est ce qui a été fait
à la marge avec les les mécanismes de
capacité mais ils sont plutôt pour
boucler les très gros risques à
l'horizon de 5 10 ans pour l'instant et
il faut le voir il faut faire la même
chose avec avec une vision à l'horizon
2050 effectivement on a absolument
besoin la PPI ne sera pas indexée sur
les prix du marché c'est un acte
politique et volontariste la PPLI si on
compte uniquement sur des indicateurs de
marché je peux vous dire la PPI tel sans
au mettre le coût des raccordements pour
l'énergie intermittente non mais le ça
coûte affreusement cher mais je je suis
d'accord enfin la PPI il faut faire un
diagnostic à côté du marché monsieur
pardonne-moi président à côté du marché
la réforme que l'Europe prépare et
l'accord politique et le truc de mise en
œuvre que la France a adopté c'est de
dire à côté des prix spot donc marcher à
très court terme on va mettre des cont à
long terme avec quelques amodiation et
cetera pour corriger un peu les échecs
du marché c'est ce qu'on va faire et
donc globalement vous n'allez pas
vraiment modifier après décembre
2025 le marché tel qu'il fonctionne avec
de la reine peut-être revu et corriger
avec un prix plafond mais il y a
peut-être pas de prix plancher s'il y a
un problème sur le marché DF peut boire
la tasse je dis ça comme je je le pense
on voit bien que dans cette affaire là
et c'est ce que moi je tentais
d'imaginer sans revenir pour autant ce
qui se faisait avant mais comment à la
faveur de cette réforme remettre du
volontarisme et préserver les intérêts
de la France tout temp en respectant des
bon c'est peut-être la cadature du
cercle mais voilà mais moi je crois pas
au seul truc du marché c'est une
illusion moi je consommateur final à à
des prix exorbitants quand les cûts de
production sont passage je comprends pas
quelle est la plusvalue de ce marché-là
en faveur des consommateurs donc c'est
on fait un bricolage la systématique
pour tenter de de mettre des un bouclier
de mettre un chèque énergie et cetera
bon voilà ça c'est ma conviction la PP
qui les investissements à long terme je
suis pas sûr que si moi j'étais un
opérateur investisseur uniquement sur
les signaux du marché sauf s'ils sont
terriblement importants avec les taux
d'actualisation je suis pas sûr du tout
que ça va orienter euh le les
investissements comme il le faudrait
c'est bien pour ça que on introduit les
les contrats pour différence dans lequel
le prix de référence on découple
c'est-à-dire on fait on constate que si
les gens anticipent les prix de marché
et prennent en compte le fait que il y a
il y a les prix mais il y a aussi le
fait il y a aussi le fait que les
investisseurs vont vont vouloir se
couvrir et demander VO de couverture des
risques donc il y a pas seulement même
le prix mais donc on va avoir
spontanément sousinvestissement du
marché et donc pour faire ça on met des
contrats à à long terme qui permettent
de d'apporter une garantie que
l'opérateur qui va faire certains
investissements qui apportent de la
puissance Garti certains investissements
qui qui apportent de la décarbonation et
qui prennent éventuellement des risques
pour qu'on apprenne sur les technologies
de décarbonation pour avoir les bonnes
technologies du futur bah lui il va être
sécurisé par rapport à son
investissement et pouvoir se financer
sur le marché et pour autant ensuite à
court terme pour le fonctionnement au
jour le jour du marché bah il va
utiliser le marché de gros il va sur le
marché de gros donc on combine à la fois
de la régulation publique par les
CFD sachant que on admet qu'on va
constater qu'il y a un écart entre ce
qui serait souhaitable comme
investissement nécessaire pour réaliser
la décarbonation et pr et la garantie
d'approvisionnement et à des coûts
abordables et puisque fait spontanément
le marché et donc on met les
instruments le problème pour ça c'est
que les gens n'anticipent pas les prix
de long terme qu'il faudrait
parce que c'est pas sûr que le prix du
carbone et cetera enfin o ils anticipent
pas ils ont des incertitudes
technologiques et cetera sou mis des ris
et donc donc on remet quelque chose qui
permet de concilier à la fois le
fonctionnement ouvert du marché et les
incitations à
l'innovationorte marché et ça on en a
plutôt plus besoin qu'on en a jamais eu
besoin dans vu les défis technologiques
qu' qu'on a à résoudre donc ça de ce
point de vue là ça ça a quand même des
des vertus et de l'autre on a un méc qui
permet de réconcilier en disant bah oui
on constate que on va peut-être pas
forcément avoir assez d'investissement
ceci étant dans le passé on l'a fait
pour les renouvelables parce que de fait
pour les renouvelables on les fait par
appel d'offre actuellement et on utilise
ce genre de mécanisme donc l'idée c'est
simplement de constater qu'il faut le
faire pour l'ensemble du marché de
l'électricité quand c'est souhaitable et
pas seulement pour une technologie
particulière
ou on a tâonné sur les dispositifs mais
donc le fait qu'avec ça on puisse
corriger et donner les les bons signaux
oui il y a besoin d'intervention
publique pour avoir le bon parc à long
terme ça il y a aucun doute là-dessus
par contre ça peut se faire dans le
cadre du marché avec les instruments qu'
qu'on pense mettre en place merci
Monsieur monsieur Jamin et après je
donne la parole juste un petit mot parce
que j'ai entendu plusieurs fois quel est
l'intérêt de notre pays là-dedans nos
consommateurs français ou notre pays au
sens large et bien sûr c'est important
je je veux quand même et et pour moi ça
va de paire c'est c'est on est on est
dans un on est embarqué avec l'Europe
là-dedans on est embarqué avec l'Europe
sur
le FIF for fiftif - 57 % d'émission de
CO2 à l'échelle européenne et la France
contribue en 2030 c'est dans 6 ans
neutralité carbone en 2050 c'est plus
loin à l'échelle européenne donc à
l'échelle française donc euh enfin il
faut il faut regarder ça et donc juste
un exemple concret ça permettrait de
répondre à vos question sur les
interconnexions parce que les
interconnexions c'est entre opérateurs
de transport d'électricité opérateurs
réguler c'est le régulateur en France la
creux dans Notes pays nos équivalents
qui régule ses opérateurs et donc et
donc qui en rôle d'approbation des
interconnexions donc on dit il faut plus
d'interconnexion il y a des plans et
cetera c'est pas une religion des
interconnexions chaque projet
d'interconnexion il est regarder avec sa
rentabilité économique c'est pas c'est
pas un gros mot c'est qu'on va regarder
combien
exactement l'interconnexion elle apporte
économiquement combien elle coûte déjà
coûte 1 milliard 2 milliards 500
millions 3 milliards ça peut très
coûteux notamment quand elle son
sous-marine et ensuite elle s'amorti sur
50 ans combien année après année elle va
irlande là en euh permettant d'exporter
plus de renouvelables qui est gratuit
dans tel pays d'en importer plus pour la
France d'exporter plus de nucléire on
regarde les parcs on regarde les
déformations on fait des scénarios quand
on est tous convaincus tous étant les
deux régulateurs nationaux que
l'équation est positive économiquement
alors on lance le projet et avant de le
lancer donc on regarde ça effectivement
à l'échelle des deux pays donc à
l'échelle quelque part aussi européenne
même si souvent c'est deux pays
concernés qui bien évidemment qu' a la
plupart des coûts et des bénéfices
et ensuite on fait aussi et là c'est la
partie un peu plus difficile ce qu'on
appelle le partage des coûts c'est la
mission des régulateurs et donc on va se
mettre d'accord pour dire que par
exemple si une opération dans laquelle
le bénéfice général il est à 70 % chez
nos voisin et à 30 % chez nous ou
inversement il va bien falloir se mettre
d'accord pour ne pas partager les coûts
5050 la règle de base est plutôt 5050
donc ça on le fait on l'a fait de
nombreuses fois on a déjà développé
largement les interconnexions depuis ces
10 et 15 prochaines dernières années on
a deux projets aujourd'hui en cours qui
sont avec l'Espagne nouvelle
interconnexion et projet
d'interconnexion sous-marine avec
l'Espagne et avec euh l'Irlande
l'Irlande avec des des des fortes
subventions européennes dans les deux
cas parce qu'il y avait un intérêt
européen voilà et et et donc c'est c'est
simplement c'est pas une religion c'est
une équation qui est regardé ça se fait
pas à n'importe quel coup il faut que
les prix les études économiques montrent
que c'est rentable
VO c'est c'est intéressant de de
l'entendre parce que j'espère que c'est
c'est le cas mais enfin les subventions
européennes c'est nous qui les payons
aussi en partie hein parce que moi j'ai
j'ai entendu dire que l'Europe voulait
investir 400 ou 500 milliards ce qui
veut dire que pour nous c'est au moins
50 milliards ou pas loin 50 milliards
c'est pas rien donc le retour je n'en
sais rien moi je moi j'aimerais bien que
vous n fassiez un petit bilan
effectivement des interconnexions
d'utilisation des
interconnexion là où elles sont elles
sont elles sont correctes ou vous jugez
qu'elles sont correctes ou suffisante et
là où elles sont insuffisantes bon
j'entends l'Espagne et l'Irlande s'il a
s'il y a ça moi ça m'intéresserait aussi
d'avoir les les études de retour sur
l'investissement qu'on pourra faire à la
fois directement et par le biais de
l'Europe parce que par le biais de
l'Europe on paye donc moi je je pense
qu'il faut il faut inclure le le montant
que que de notre participation
européenne dans dans le dans le cadre de
ces subventions voilà moi je je je
demande à être convaincu et que la
Commission soit convaincue cu de
l'utilité et et de la bonne étude
préalable des des dossiers sachant que
euh si on donne pas notre accord la
France peut bloquer ces interconnexions
j'imagine j'imagine que c'est on n'est
pas soumis à une décision européenne
qu'il s'imposerait à nous une obligation
de 70 % de disponibilité oui alors il y
a tout un process qui est qui qui est
complexe lorsquon projet est très avancé
et notamment que tout est toujours
complexe dans
le je je peux pas répondre j'aurais bien
aimé répondre par ouiou par non ce n'est
pas si facile que ça je ne peux pas
répondre oui la France peut bloquer tout
ce qu'elle veut ce n'est pas
complètement exa lorsqu'un projet
d'interconnexion a été identifié comme
projet d'intérêt général européen dans
une liste qui est mise à jour tous les 2
ans et ça veut dire qu'il existe qu'il a
été quelque part porté en France par RTE
avec un homologue lorsqu'il est dans
cette liste là il est quand même quelque
part dans le tunnel il a vocation à se
réaliser un jour ou l'autre donc il
avance il avance il avance et il revient
aux régulateurs
nationaux de prendre une décision
conjointe s'ils arrivent à une décision
conjointe de dire l'opération n'est pas
rentable le projet est enterré c'est
d'ailleur ce qui s'est passé sur une
alors c'est du gaz hein sur une fameuse
interconnexion gaz s'ppelit MC à
l'époque un milliard d'euros on avait
réussi à se mettre d'accord le
régulateur espagnol pour enterrer ce
projet qui était très fortement soutenu
à l'époque par la Commission européenne
les deux ne sont pas d'accord si les
deux régulateurs ne se mettent pas
d'accord l'arbitrage final revient à
l'Acer qui est l'agence de coopération
des régulateur européen et dans la
charge pour nous dans ce cas de
convaincre notre homologue qu'il faut
faire t interconnexion si lui s'y oppose
ou au contraire qu'il ne faut pas la
faire si c'est nous qui nous yosé qui
nous y opposons on n'a jamais rencontré
ce cas est toujours tombé d'accord avec
nos homologues sur où il faut faire non
il ne faut pas faire céit le cas de4
avec Espagne et oui il faut faire avec
quel partage de prix pas quel partage de
coût jusqu'à présent en tout cas si vous
pouvez nous apporter des élément
là-dessussolument
laie une fois tous les de ans un rapport
sur le fonctionnement des interconn
connexion électrique et gazière donc le
prochain va devrait être en avril ou mai
ou juin de cette année pas la date
exacte mais au moins les prédécesseurs
qui analyse notamment l'utilisation des
interconnexions voilà et soyez vraiment
convaincu que pendant en tout cas
pendant en 2022 vous avez
peut-être pas forcément cette
information les interconnexions utilisé
absolument à plein dans tous les sens
vous imaginez que lorsque le prix monte
à 3400 500 € en cas de crise ça veut
dire que en fonction des pays les écarts
sont énormes et ces interconnexions ser
stabilisé par les écarts de prix donc en
2022 RTE a reçu alors qu'il reçoit
généralement dans son dans son revenu 3
à 400 millions d'euros par an a reçu 2
milliards d'euros de plus 2 milliards 3
euh de recettes des interconnexions il y
avait tellement de revenus qu'on savait
plus quoi en faire donc le régulateur a
a a dit enfin dans un monde général
évidemment où les coûts étaient énormme
mais néanmoins ces 2 milliards ont été
redistribué exceptionnellement en une
fois en tout en janvier 2023 la fin de
l'année 2022 par RTE à bah au
consommateurs industriels consommant
beaucoup qui sont rattachés directement
à son réseau donc ils ont reçu
directement un chèque et pour le reste à
nedis pour venir baisser le tarif de
réseau d'enedis puisquen fait c'est
enedis qui utilise est connecté au
réseau de transport voilà donc c'est
cette année là les interconnexions ont
été extrêmement utiles physiquement et
ont généré beaucoup de revenus aussi
pour
RTE oui désolé juste juste une petite
dernière parce que je je sens bien la
petite tendance aussi c'est de se dire
que on a vécu presque un âge d'or où on
était bien en France et que dans les
années 90 ù avec notre parc nucléaire ça
allait très bien moi moi j'aimerais bien
une petite analyse aussi à cette époque-
làà où on a été quand même en sur en
surproduction pendant assez longtemps en
France peut peut-être que je me trompe
justement j'aimerais bien avoir une
vision là-dessus et euh à cette époque
là est-ce qu'on a vendu vraiment de
l'énergie plus ou moins à perte au
niveau au niveau européen et puis moi ce
que j'ai vu c'est aussi qu'on a avoir
une très forte production de nucléaire
ce n'était pas forcément adapté non plus
à la consommation c'est c'est pour ça
que l'on avait des moments de très
fortes surproduction et que on se
rappelle que EDF incitait quand même à
chauffer à fond chez soi et même la nuit
et même quand on
partait voilà ça on n'est pas allé dans
dans ce volet efficacité énergétique que
moi j'appelle de mes vœux on a vu que
c'était notre pays était très
thermosensible il faut vraiment aller
aussi vers l'écrêage de la pointe et il
fut un temps d'ailleurs il y avait on
l'a un peu évoqué mais il y avait les
tarifs JP qui permettaiit à un moment
d'avoir un vrai signal prix parce que
moi je pense aussi que le consommateur
doit être responsabilisé parce que les
investissements ce sont des
investissements nationaux et pour le
très long terme donc il faut qu'il y ait
un sign signal prix qui soit présent et
je pense qu'on pendant un moment et bien
on l'a un peu oublié ce signal prix donc
il faut qu'il soit là mais d'une manière
on va dire je pense que c'est partagé
d'une manière raisonnable c'est-à-dire
que on a bien vu là que dans ce moment
de crise là c'était devenu insupportable
aussi bien pour les entreprises que pour
les les citoyens
lambda merci par queoui Monsieur merci
beaucoup ça me permettra dire un mot sur
le surmenté de vente c'est un point un
point important qu'il faut qu'il faut
évoquer alors sur les années 90 c'est
c'est un peu le problème qu'on a c'était
une année de au 80 de dynamique très
forte de croissance très forte
probablement il faud voir historiens de
du secteur qu'on av anticipé une
croissance de la consommation plus forte
qu'elle existait qu'on se'est retrouve
en sur capacité et voilà c'est tout le
problème de mais ça c'est la difficulté
qui a déjà été été
évoqué sur les signaux de prix oui on
les avait un peu oublié mais enfin là on
les a pour le coup un peu trop vu
pendant la crise je pense que même même
si même si on le marché a fait ce qu'il
était prévu de faire il a eu des effets
quand même extrêmement mauvais en terme
de alors c'est important aussi pas
tellement la volatilité simplement un
niveau général des prix qui était
extrêmement élevé la volatilité des
heures à zéro où il y a trop de
renouvelabl et des heures à 2 300 il en
a pas assez et il faut payer des
centrales de pointe extrêmement coûteuse
ça on va en avoir de plus en plus il
faut il faut en être conscient
simplement c'est que le prix le prix
moyen doit rester à un niveau correct et
et et les signaux de prix effectivement
il faut les avoir alors je voulais
vraiment dire un petit mot sur les tarif
réglementé de vente parce que je je
voudrais clarifier quand même que côté
du régulateur il est absolument certain
et évident que nous avons besoin des
tarifs réglementés de vente pour un
futur prévisible peut-être qu'un jour on
pourrair marché pur et parfait on en
aura pas besoin donc ça il y a aucun
doute là-dessus il représente
aujourd'hui encore les 2/ers du marché
chez les consommateurs particuliers et
chez les consommateurs TPE t petit à peu
près c'est à peu près la même proportion
la question des signaux de prix par
exemple sur les sur les sur les tar
rglementé de vente est vraiment une
question importante c'est vrai que on
voit qu'on aura besoin de plus en plus
que les consommateurs se saisissent de
leur consommation et utilisent la
flexibilité qui est la leure certaines
consommateurs n'en on aucune donc
généraliser une flexibilité pour tout le
monde cela ça veut dire qu'on va les
pénaliser et si SS sont précaires il va
falloir les aider parce que sinon ça
fonctionnera pas par exemple on pourrait
dire on met pour tout le monde aux
heures de pointe un petit signal
suppémentaire plus cher mais si vous
n'avez qu'un chauffage électrique vous
avez une passeoire thermique si vous
faites ça vous allez payer plus cher les
gens ils avaient tous leur petit poê et
quand c'était ou leur cheminée à
l'époque et quand et quand ça s'allumait
il coupaiit toute l'électricité dans la
maison mais effectivement il fallait ils
avaient une alternative il faut bien
unealternative ilo aujourd'hui qui
existe toujours eux et qui sont toujours
offerts et et d'ailleurs pendant la
crise ils ont été ils ont été il y a eu
une une campagne un peu commerciale de
redéveloppement de ces tarif impô qui
avait pas été qui existait toujours mais
qui était pas vraiment voilà don donc ça
c'est mesô c'est vraiment des choses
pour personne Ave averti parce que vous
payez extrêmement cher les jours de
pointe et c'est pendant 10 he donc vous
devez vous pouvez pas initeur 1 heure il
faut vraiment donc voilà et et en
revanche toute l'année vous êtes bien
donc mais sinon il y a tout ce qui est
he plein creuse c'est important c'est
quand même la moitié à peu près des
consommateurs concernés donc là il y a
un signal c'est efficace et cetera et
puis c'est vrai qu'il y a une moitié de
consommateurs qui sont sur tarif base où
là il y a aucun signal il faut réfléchir
à tout ça donc on est en train de lancer
une réflexion sur les airpl CR on voit
bien aussi que pour l'instant les Cruz
sont la nuit on voit bien et là c'est le
marché qui nous le dit
on voit bien que on voit bien que les
heures méridiennes safent en hiver et on
a de plus en plus de photovoltaïqu donc
on se rend compte que le marché nous dit
il faudrait mettre des heures creuse
entre MIDH 16h quelque part en été au
printemps à l'automne parce que parce
que c'est il y a trop d' a beaucoup
d'électricité bon on est en train de
réfléchir à tout ça c'est transformation
importante les gens sont habitués ils
ont le régime de pleer CR depuis des
années des années des années on n a pas
touché très peu toucher donc il faut
réfléchir à tout ça en tout cas le
régulateur travaille à faire des
propositions au pouvoir public dans
direction c'est une des dimension de la
flexibilité côté côté consommateur
exactement exactement qui pour l'instant
n voilà qui qui qu'ense utile petit à
petit d'adresser pour le pour le système
dernière intervention monsieur bureau
oui alors je je de petits mots un petit
mot qui est sur l'anecdote mais monsieur
va partir en fait sur on a cru enfin
certains ont cru pendant longtemps qu'on
allait responsabiliser consommateur à
l'effacement grâce au marché de gros
effectivement on vient plutôt
aujourd'hui euh à essayer de voir
comment stimuler partout les opérateurs
et qu' y a de la compétition entre les
appérateurs mais plutôt pour mettre des
dispositifs qui ressemblent peut-être un
peu plus mais qui utilisent aussi les
technologies qu'on peut avoir en terme
de comptage et cetera mais donc
effectivement il y a il y a des
évolutions et euh et ça c'est je pense
que ça ça ça change un peu la la
perspective quoi c'est-à-dire que on
cherche vraiment à utiliser au mieux les
les différents instruments le le non le
de dernier point c'est sur l'âge d'or
que que vous évoquez euh ce qui est sûr
c'est que dans les décennies 90 2000
début des années 2000 on avait du
nucléaire qui était pas cher et on avait
du gaz qui était pas cher donc
effectivement naviguer quand il fait par
be temps les gens savent faire
finalement mieux et on pouvait discuter
à l'infini est-ce que il y a un peu trop
de gaz pas enfin pas assez de gaz bon et
cetera et sans doute àépoque on disait
oui on aurait puon et cetera il faut se
rendre compte que le problème de
décarbonation dont dont on a pris la
mesure que très progressivement avant le
rapport RTE RTE nous écrivait qu'on
pouvait fermer une centrale nucléaire
tous les 3 ans des machins comme ça on
avait pas pris la mesure à quel point
fabriquer euh pouvoir fournir 35 % plus
d'électricité et qu'elle soit décarboné
avec la sécurité d'approvisionnement et
produite à des coûts de production on
savait absolument pas faire et je pense
que donc on est vraiment enfin
prospectivement on est vraiment dans un
malheureusement on est dans on est au
pied du mur où on n pas trouvé forcément
encore bien bien la voix je crois que
c'est pour ça
que je pense que vous avez raison de
demander plus d'évaluation expose plus
systématique mais il faut le faire avec
actu et se rendre compte que en
prospective on est vraiment dans un
monde et avec des défis qui sont qui
n'ont rien à
voir merci merci à vous tous merci
beaucoup merci
merci